Ah, hello!
Hello everybody!
Give me a sec, I'm getting a tour guide.
I'm getting a tour guide because like, I joined the server and I was like, this is overwhelming.
Okay, so, cause like, okay, I'm joining in like, very late, by the way, to the server.
The server is literally gonna be shut down in like, two days.
And I did get invited on launch and then so I was just like, I was like looking at the...
I was looking at the like, other streamers playing it and I was like, holy fuck, people are building mansions!
Mansions are already being built!
And I was just like, bro, what am I doing here?
I joined in so fucking late.
Um...
Yes, these servers are always like, uh, they're only there for like, cause it's like a content thing.
So for those who don't know, Rust Kingdoms is actually like a tw- Usually, I think it's like, majority Twitch streamers are on the server because of Twitch drops.
Just pretend you're getting drops on my stream.
Uh, just cause like, there's like, exclusive drops right now for everybody that's participating in the server.
But like, I'm not on Twitch, so...
So we'll pretend we're like, guys!
Oh my god!
If you watch five hours of this stream, you might be able to get that exclusive anime drop in Rust, guys!
Guys, I swear, just link your Steam account to YouTube, guys!
Um...
Uh, so...
Okay, let me see.
Uh, apparently...
Okay, so Gumi is gonna be my tour guide because I was like, okay, maybe I'll just...
Maybe I'll just like, you know, wing this.
And like...
Maybe I'll like, meet somebody, like, by chance.
But then I...
I was looking at...
Like, just like, researching a little bit how the server's like.
And it is fucking wild.
Like, it's...
It's wild!
Um...
And, uh...
And like, Gumi was telling me like, by the way, the Kingdom server is fucking wild.
Because like, it's like a...
It's like when you're at the Wild West and then, uh...
Like, it's anything goes type situation.
Like, that type of deal.
So...
So like, I'm worried I'm gonna get like, robbed and...
Because I'm just a baby!
I literally...
I'm starting today!
So...
That's why I was like...
I was like, fuck, I think I might need like, protection.
I might need a bodyguard.
So I hit up...
I hit up Gumi like, last second.
Like, literally like, five minutes before...
Uh...
Before the stream started.
I was like, oh no, I'm chickening out.
I don't think I can...
I don't think I can do this by myself.
Because at first I was like, okay, Doki.
Be fucking brave.
You got this, Doki.
You can do this by yourself.
You don't need a chaperone.
And then five minutes before the stream started, I cracked.
I was like, no I do.
I need a chaperone.
I...
Please, somebody.
I am a baby.
Somebody help me.
Oh no, it's night time.
I talked too long and now it's night time!
No!
Now I definitely need a chaperone.
I need an adult.
I am lost.
Oh god.
Shots.
Oh my god, there's shots out there too!
People are shooting at each other!
And I'm just sleeping on the ground naked!
Guys.
That is why...
Like the last...
Oh so by the way guys, I don't know if you guys noticed this but I did start...
I did start like 30 minutes later because I literally woke up at 11.30.
I was so fucking tired.
I was really exhausted.
I don't know.
I think like it's just everything like keep crashing down.
That's...
I didn't eat dinner last night.
Because all I did was like I just slept after the stream.
I was so fucking tired.
And then I just kept sleeping.
I would wake up and I was like, oh I think I could sleep a little bit more.
I even set alarms and everything.
I set alarms and everything.
But I still like went back to sleep.
So I've been like...
I've been like so tired.
That's why I have to push back the stream 30 minutes later.
Because I was like, oh man.
I can't.
I need more time to like reset my schedule.
Like I need more time to rebuild my energy.
Oh, it's daytime again.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm typing Gumi.
Okay.
Is it free to call now?
Gumi will take care of me.
She's rich too.
I'm pretty sure she's rich and rest.
She's been playing since launch day.
I know you can gamble.
I saw a lot of people gambling already.
Do you think she'll like donate to me for me to gamble?
You think so?
Do you think guys do you think you think she'll give me guys?
I bet you should give me money.
I She's rich.
Oh, she has to pee.
Give me a sec guys.
Okay, you know what?
We can wake up.
What the fuck?
There's a castle behind me.
Holy shit.
Where am I?
Let's let's let's turn down this sensitivity.
Where is sensitivity?
Oh picks.
Does it really matter?
Where the fuck is?
I'll control the area.
It should be the sense area.
Malice sensitivity.
When aiming down.
Oh wait, there's we don't need that.
Okay, 0.6 area.
Oh, I mean lower.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Everybody's fucking rich.
I got you to kind.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Bro.
What the fuck?
Bro, the servers only been out for like how many days has served it up?
One to do this.
This is like four days.
What the fuck happened in four days?
It's like a town.
Don't worry.
I had it pixelated.
It's like a fucking town.
The Hussey and Ender.
Holy shit.
That is a fucking town.
I got civilization.
Oh my God.
This is actually crazy.
In four days?
Is it?
Race players.
Oh hey, it's a horse.
Is it somebody horse?
Hold down use to open.
I'm sorry.
How do I steal their horse?
Whose horse is this?
How do I ride it?
Oh, it's locked in.
Wait, can I accidentally kill somebody's horse?
Aww.
Anything goes.
Wait, can I actually?
Wait!
Oh!
Yoink.
I guess it's my horse now.
Yay!
Okay, I'm gonna message Gumi.
I stole a horse.
Oh my god!
I have a horse!
I think people will be okay.
I think... I mean, they're rich!
There's no law here!
Oh my god!
Gumi's gonna pick me up with her car!
Okay, I'm gonna call her.
I'm gonna call her.
Oh my god, pick up the phone.
She's got... she has a car!
And I have a horse.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
I can't believe it.
Guys, I just joined the game and I already have a horse, guys.
Guys, she already has a horse.
I stole a horse!
I don't know whose horse... whose horse this is!
Was it just out in the open?
It was like next to this castle.
Oh!
Whose castle is that?
Am I gonna make an enemy?
They won't know it's me, right?
No, no, no.
Horses are easy to come by.
Oh, okay.
So they won't care about this missing horse.
Yeah, they just upped the spawn rate.
So it should be okay.
Yay!
Free castle horse!
Oh my god.
You might get shot on sight.
Wait, what?
While I'm on a horse?
But I'm naked!
Motherfuckers don't care.
Oh my god.
Here, there's some sweats and dessert for you.
Oh my god, I hear the shots.
I hear the shots.
I hear the shots in the distance.
I'm scared.
Okay, oh my god.
How do I like make it so like the fucking horse doesn't like bounce up?
Oh my god.
A motion blur?
There's a motion blur.
Hello?
Are you an Earper?
What's an Earper?
I just joined.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
I just found this horse like five seconds ago.
Oh, welcome.
Oh fuck, you logged on at a wild time.
Why?
Everyone's doing wars right now.
Wait!
What?
Hello.
Give me all your money right now.
I just got in.
I'm homeless.
No, not my horse.
I just... No!
Not my horse.
I just found a horse.
Please!
What did she do to you?
That's my dog.
I'm literally... All I have is my horse, sir.
That's all I have.
Oh my god.
Give me all the... They're shooting me in my horse!
They're shooting me in my horse!
No!
Stop talking to him!
It's Espen!
I'm telling you, there's nachos everywhere.
Bro!
She literally ran up to me and was like, give me all your money.
And I was like, I don't have anything.
I just have a horse.
I'm telling you, there's freaks.
There's freaks.
There are freaks!
They just shot my horse!
The horse that I saw!
I'm telling you ahead of time, horses cannot go down rocks or stuff.
They can't climb.
You have to take them to a hill.
Oh my god, bro.
One of them was like, run away!
What do you mean there's war?
I literally just got here and there's a fucking war?
Oh, there's another horse.
How do I get off this horse?
I'm gonna steal this horse.
Uh, jump the space.
My other horse has like no health now.
Alright, sound guy, how's the...
Okay, I'm a ginger.
What?
Also, sound guy, oh shit, sorry.
Sound guy, I hope the sound's okay.
Sound guy, good luck.
Good luck.
The sounds are so hard to balance in this game.
Where are you, Gumi?
I'm at the castle where the guy that shot me was.
Okay, hold G for me.
Yeah?
Okay.
I'm here.
There's a church.
Uh, Q... Q5.
Next to the... I'm like almost close to Q6.
Okay, so if you're at the church, that's the church of the blood god.
And...
Oh, I...
Don't these sound cool?
Yeah, they might ask for you to die a couple times for them.
Wait, why?
For the blood god.
Oh, I mean, that sounds right.
What?
Yo, wait, I wanna check out the blood god.
Sounds pretty cool.
Wait, that's... I was next to the blood god church!
One of the guys shot... One of the guys that tried to mug me was the blood god disciple.
Maybe.
Wait, wait, I'll wait for you at the blood god.
Okay, if you stay inside and... it might be safe.
It might be safe?
It's like a safe place?
I'm running around.
No.
Well...
Oh.
Maybe.
Wait.
There's not really a safe place anymore.
What?
I'm telling you...
At this time of day, there's wars going on where like 40 people go to invade another base and then...
What the fuck?
They're usually fighting in the middle of the map and everything.
What?
Okay, I'm on the server.
I'm in my car.
I'm on my way.
Okay.
I'm just checking out the church.
Yeah, I'll even bring you food too.
Oh, thank god.
I think I'm starving and dying of thirst right now.
Wait.
Is there a casino?
I know Russ has casino.
There's multiple.
There's multiple?
Can you bring me to the biggest casino?
And can I like... can you like lend me some cash?
What?
You know I'm good for it, Gumi.
You know I can repay you.
I have a horse.
Your horse owl will take it.
Oh, you almost died?
No, I ditched that one and I stole another one.
So like I have two horses now, technically.
Yeah.
You know, I'll loan you the horse.
The horse is my deposit.
Yeah, sure.
I'll give you the horse's collateral.
I don't need horses.
I'll be honest.
I have a car.
Yeah, but like it's not the same as a horse.
The horse is cuter.
No, I actually have two horses too.
Yeah, but my horse is orange.
Orange?
Yeah, just like me because I'm Ginger on the server.
Oh, hey, it's daytime.
Yeah, I'm Ginger.
You'll see me.
Okay.
Do you have your cock and balls out or something?
Yeah, I do.
I don't have clothes.
I look down and it's just pixels.
Oh my god.
I'm driving over right now.
I hear more gunshots.
I took my fastest car for you.
I hear more gunshots coming.
I'm so scared.
Please.
My first experience with strangers was that they tried to mug me.
And I was broke.
I got mugged.
Yeah.
There's gonna be a lot of that.
Wait.
I'm on my way over right now.
Okay, I'll wait for you.
Guys, don't worry.
I twerk.
Is that you?
I see you!
Wait, no, that is not me.
Okay, I know who he was running away from.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I saw...
There's like...
Gumi, I'm a little scared because there's a lot of gunshots around me.
Yeah.
I know where I'm not going.
That's for sure.
Wait, how's... What's your house like?
I live with Abe and them.
Oh shit.
You live with the admin?
Yeah.
Wait, do you guys get benefits?
Not that I know of.
Wait, but you live with the admin.
Oh my god.
I see people chasing my...
Leave my stuff so help me Jesus.
I'm scared.
Is that what one of them said?
Yeah, that's what Cutie Cinderella said in chat.
Ah.
I can't believe it.
You're with the admin.
Yeah.
Oh my god, there's a huge crowd over there.
Oh my god, they just killed somebody.
I just saw them murder.
Okay, I'm on the road.
I'm currently... If you held G, I'm at L15.
L15.
I'm on my way.
Is that you?
Girl, I said L15, man.
Oh my god, there's another car heading towards me.
I hope they don't run me over.
No, no, no.
Did you die?
It's been...
Okay,
respond again and let me know where you are.
Where am I?
Okay.
I am... I am... I am at P2.
P2?
I... Look, I... Okay, I'll start running.
I'll start running.
No, no.
Just go back.
Don't go back to the church.
You can...
Just head to the nearest road and then hide in a tree or something.
Oh, I found another horse!
Okay, like... I... I... I... Okay.
When I noticed it was Espen, I was like, I'm gonna die.
I'm so dead.
I got ran over by Espen.
I can't believe... They didn't even give me a warning.
They just ran me over.
They just... They just fucking ran me over, Goomy.
What is this town?
Yeah...
What... What are these Neanderthals here?
Yeah... They're very much...
Uka-Buka... Get down.
Get down.
Give me your money.
Yeah...
I just thought... I just thought they would give me a warning.
You know?
Okay, I am at... I am at Q4.
Where are you at?
Q4?
Yeah.
I'm currently at P9 if you wanna run this way.
P9?
Where the fuck is P?
Guys, where is P9?
Chat.
Wait, that's so far!
Wait, no.
That's not so far.
That's almost there.
Okay.
Oh.
There's gunshots around me, Goomy.
I'm scared.
Yeah...
I'm so scared.
Okay.
I'm slowly walking on the road.
Ooh.
That's a nice bar.
Wow.
This is a nice town.
Oh.
P9.
Okay.
I'm on the road.
So you might bump into me while I'm walking on the road.
Well, I mean, I'm naked.
Why would they hurt a naked person?
Oh.
Do not go on the road.
Girl, you just got killed.
Okay, but I...
You got hit twice.
Okay, but it was S-Fan.
So like, it was... like, you know, it's... it's...
Maybe the other people are nicer.
Wait, why do I not go on the road?
Um... There might be a lot of people that shoot you on the road.
Huh?
But I'm naked.
Okay.
Where... where are you?
I'm on... R5.
R5?
Okay.
I'm on my way.
Oh, there's a sheriff's office.
Yeah... That's not real.
Oh.
What do you mean?
What do you mean that's not real?
They're not real.
They're not...
They're...
Are you telling me that there's no laws here?
But...
But this is a town.
They have the thrifty cow.
They have the sheriff's office.
There was a bar earlier.
It's a trap.
Wait, is the sheriff's office a trap?
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
Where... where are you?
I'm at R... You're at R5, right?
Yes.
I'm... Oh, is that you?
Is that your car?
Wait, you're the wrong person.
Hello?
No, I'm here.
This is me.
Oh my God, you're naked too.
Shadi, get in.
Okay, wait.
What about my horse?
No, I'm not.
It's because my chicken can't fit.
Look.
Oh.
Wait, that's so cool.
Wait, can I bring my horse over?
No, I'll give you a better horse.
Oh, okay.
Wait, how do I... how do I get in?
I have to unlock the door.
Get in, hurry.
Oh, I hear shots.
I hear shots.
Oh my God.
Logan, move.
Logan, hurry.
Wait, who the fuck is that guy?
Beaten Tekken.
Bro, that's the guy killed in Tekken.
Yeah.
He was in the senior's lab.
I was like, wait a minute.
I remember Logan.
All right.
Where are we going first?
Yeah, he was the Hwadong player.
Yeah, he was that fucking guy that beat the shit out of me in the first round.
And then he beat the shit out of me in the second round.
All right.
Why are we AFK?
Gumi, what's going on?
Gumi, what?
I'm gonna take you to safer areas in, um, of the server, okay?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
That's fine.
That sounds nice.
Okay, let me, uh...
I'm gonna talk to you on Discord because I can't hear over the driving.
Wait, not even with your audio stuff?
No.
It's like...
It depends on the car and sometimes if I'm driving in this specific car, it's really loud.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Oh shit, sorry.
What the fuck?
You didn't need that window, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I didn't need it.
How do I?
I don't know how to shi- What was that?
Don't look.
What?
What was that?
Don't look.
Are we getting chased?
Are we?
No, no, no.
Just don't look.
No, there's- nobody's chasing us now.
We're okay.
We're safe.
Yeah, because I'm speeding away.
They would just shoot a car like that?
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
We're like innocent bystanders.
You should tell them.
Radiation poisoning?
Oh.
Hey, are you okay?
You know how- how- how- Yeah?
Why am I getting radiation poisoning?
Is it- is it gone yet?
14 seconds.
Where did you take me?
Here, come here.
Okay.
Yeah?
So you can have this, this.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Water too?
I'm rich.
Eat up and drink up in the car.
Oh wait, I can- wait, you locked it.
Sorry, there you go.
How do I eat?
Uh, you can right click it or no, click in your inventory.
Yeah?
Oh, okay, eat.
Alright, nice.
Oh, nice!
And I get corn too!
Oh my god, I feel so pampered right now.
That's my sugar daddy, guys.
That's my sugar daddy.
Doctor.
Gumi, can I get- can I get some cash for the casino?
Whoa.
Look out.
Yeah, don't talk about cash on the streets, you know it's what like-
Oh my god.
Are we going to your house right now?
Yeah.
Oh my god, guys.
Let me just make sure we're going the right way.
Oh, okay.
Guys!
Gumi's gonna take me to her house!
Put clothes on?
But that's what- that's what my sugar daddy looks like.
Yeah, I like her naked.
Oh my god.
Gumi said if I stop wearing clothes, she'll lend me money for the casino.
Hey, don't worry, baby.
I got clothes for you at home.
Oh, yay!
Some from Victoria's Secret, if you know that.
Oh yay!
Oh my god, you have a whole gated community?
Girl, this is not the community.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
But there is one.
I'll take you to it.
Oh my god.
Wait, how many houses do you have?
Yeah, about 20.
What?
Oh my god.
Guys, I scored one.
Oh my god, I'm set for life.
I can hear you.
As long as I look pretty for you, it's okay, right?
Yeah.
Oh, you see that?
There's a bear.
Wait, there's a bear.
Oh my god, where?
Yeah, you don't want to look at it.
Wait, I want to look at the bear.
Oh.
What?
Okay.
Yeah, I want to see it.
I mean, your car is faster than the bear, right?
It is.
Yay!
Oh, see?
Look!
Oh my god, guys!
It's like a wildlife safari.
Guys, there's a bear.
Guys, look!
Wait, wait, make him chase us.
Yeah, give me one second.
Let me just...
That would be so cool.
That would be so funny.
Look!
Look at guys!
It's just like wildlife safari!
Oh my god, it's just like those arcade games where the bear follows you.
You know those arcade machines where you had the safari animals run at you?
It's just like that.
Alright, this is my home.
This?
Uh-huh.
Wait.
Wait, it's all that is yours?
Look at the front.
Oh, oh!
Wait, your house is in a cave.
Wait, I want to check it out.
What happened?
This is my garage.
You have a garage?
Oh, I want to check it out.
So this is your cave home?
Yeah, I can't let you in there because I don't know what your grubby little hands will grab.
I would not grab anything!
You know that!
You know I wouldn't grab anything, Gumi!
You can trust me!
I'm your trophy wife!
Look at this!
Ooh, what is that?
Jelly's Taxi Service.
Oh.
Distraction.
Wait, you can call it a taxi?
How do you call it a taxi?
Wait, I wanna... Gumi, wait, where did you go?
I'm inside.
Oh, you're inside?
Gumi, let me in!
Yeah, I'll give you a gun too, okay?
A gun!
Yay!
Ooh, but clothes.
Should I have clothes on?
Yeah, you might get radiation poisoning if you don't.
Okay.
Please, I promise I won't steal your items.
Gumi, I promise.
Gumi, I prom...
Let me in.
Last time, Abe...
Abe said...
Let me in.
Abe said he was gonna beat my ass if I let people in.
I'll be your dirty little secret!
The hell?
Don't worry!
They won't know!
I'm good at keeping secrets!
Oh no.
Yeah, but it's a thrill, you know?
We both have our little secret.
The thrill of it.
We'll keep it just between us!
Come on!
I wanna see how cool your house is on the inside!
Come on, Gumi!
Come on!
You can't just leave me shivering and cold on the outside!
Uh oh.
Team mate's here.
Nobody's here.
What are you talking about?
Oh!
Hello!
My friend.
She just joined today.
Yeah, I'm new here.
Okay, welcome.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh my god.
A mace?
And a guitar?
Yeah.
I'm gonna teach you how to get money.
Wait... I'm not gonna make money then.
How do I play it?
Take it out in your hand.
Put it in your hand.
PUT IT IN YOUR HAND!
I'm a busker!
Hold right click.
Yeah?
Hold it down, man.
I'm doing it!
Now you're playing.
How do I play other notes?
Here you go.
Oh, and I also get a gun?
That's a baby gun for babies.
It's okay.
I can defend myself now.
Alright.
How...
Have you played Rust before?
N-W-Once.
Do you know how to get money?
No.
Okay, get in.
Don't worry, I'll play for us.
Well, life can be so beautiful sometimes.
Isn't it beautiful?
My services are one note per...
uh...
uh... one scrap per note.
I'll take you out of this goddamn car and take your clothes.
But for you it's free!
Just so you know.
Here you go.
Isn't it beau- Do you think your teammate knew I wanted to...
break in?
Yeah.
Oh.
You think they're friendly?
What if I come out?
We should go there and I'll play them a song.
And I'll tell them I'm here to busk for money.
Oh, it's okay.
It's just Leslie and Foolish fighting over there.
I'll take you...
I'll take you to the castle.
The castle?
Is it the one up front?
Is that your house?
Yeah, it's an actual gated community.
Wait, that's a gated community?
How do we get inside?
You have to have the code.
What's the code?
Sorry, my car was too close.
Um, I can't tell you until you join the gated community.
But I can...
I can earn my way up there.
I'm here plus one.
Yeah, you have to be here with me every time I clock in.
Yeah, but like...
I should get the code too because like...
I'm good for it, you know?
Oh my god, that's another horse.
Yeah, how do I know you're not gonna steal that guy's horse?
Look, I looked at the horse.
It doesn't mean I actually was gonna steal it.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's a bar!
Oh, Tina's here!
Who's here?
Here, let's park here.
Okay.
Grandpa!
Wait!
Hi grandpa!
I brought my friend.
She just joined today.
Yeah, she just joined today.
She gave me clothes and a guitar.
Really?
Cool.
I think Tina's here too.
Oh.
You wanna help me test something?
Oh yeah, sure.
What is it?
Wait, actually...
Does it involve death?
Can you go inside here?
Oh yeah, sure.
No, no, no.
No killing.
Okay, no killing.
Okay, sure.
I think he's just testing if it works electronically.
Oh!
It's like a prison cell!
Hello.
Me?
What?
Oh my god, there's like...
Wait, what?
What?
Wait, wait, wait!
No!
Nightmare!
Wait, wait, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
Was it scary?
Yes, it was very scary.
I have trauma now.
Okay, I'm gonna eat.
Oh, perfect.
Perfect?
What the fuck?
Yeah, I'm telling you, there's freaks everywhere.
Oh my god!
You're friends with him?
That's my grandpa.
Wait, do I get paid for this?
I played a song.
Do I...
Do I get paid for testing it?
What?
That's no money.
What do you mean no money?
I tested it for you.
My services aren't cheap.
Donkey run inside!
Donkey run!
Thank you!
Thank you, sir.
Here's a free song.
No problem.
Wait, why run inside?
Why run inside?
Did you not hear those gunshots just now?
No, I was too busy begging for money.
Welcome to the castle.
Hahaha!
Wow!
Wait, there are so many other instruments!
Yeah, here.
Wait, play the piano!
Let's start a band!
We should start a band.
Oh my god.
I think we sound great!
Oh my god, we sound so good together.
This barely a song.
Wait, how much?
He gave me $33!
$33!
Wait, did they build all of this?
Or was this castle here already?
Castle is...
They built a castle for everyone.
Oh, wait.
So it was already here.
Like...
So then they just took over the castle.
Oh, because it's a kingdom!
Yeah, if you look over here...
So Foolish is the king.
And Tina is the princess.
And so is Mi-young.
Mi-young is the princess.
Mi-young is also a princess.
Okay, what are you in the castle hierarchy?
Oh, I'm the god.
You're the god?
Look at me!
Do I not look like a god?
I mean, you were like naked for half of it, so...
Well, that's because my chicken can't fit in the car.
A god would make it fit.
Okay.
Wait, wait, then I'm your...
Wait, then what am I?
Because I'm your friend!
Slash trophy winner!
Oh, yeah, you're this...
You're this homeless dude I picked up off the road.
What?
Wait, what's this button do?
That makes you join the kingdom, I think.
Oh, okay.
Wait, are you part of the rusty bones kingdom?
For now, but I think I might...
Wait, why?
You're not like the rusty bones?
I think I need to live a nomad life.
Oh, just like me!
Well, you don't live it by choice.
You don't know that!
You don't fucking know that!
I just love it!
I love this life!
Wait, if you leave, that means the god spot is like left open.
Yeah, it is.
So there would be like, you know, like a hole to fill.
And you know, you know, maybe I would take the god spot.
T-Rex birth.
So, I'll teach you something about the lore.
Hold down G.
Okay.
See the amount of your map?
Yeah.
Right now we're on the bottom left, right?
This is the rusty bones.
It's the friendly kingdom that lets you build your own little house outside.
Uh-huh.
And you can live as a community.
All the way on the right, on the bottom right corner, It's T-Rocket!
Those are the meatheads.
As they call themselves.
Wait, isn't that word what Mendo's team is?
Yeah.
That's where they don't really build houses.
They only build gun bases.
No!
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Um...
On the top right is the one true kingdom, OTK.
Yeah.
And on the top left is the underworld, which is Iron Mouse's domain.
Uh-huh.
Um...
I'll be honest, I've not visited them and I don't want to.
I'm scared.
In the underworld?
Why?
Well, the underworld is cool.
But the thing is...
Um... So, I have three separate houses.
I took you to one.
I have one with Kenji.
Yeah.
And I have one with Boxbox.
Uh-huh.
Um...
Kenji got shot up yesterday.
In the underworld?
Yeah.
I'll play a song for your lore story.
And apparently they're gonna make you work really hard.
Oh, I don't like working.
I just want to play my guitar.
Yeah, you don't like working?
This place is the right place for you.
Everyone will give you stuff for free.
Really?
I mean, you did.
But like, that guy That guy shocked me though.
Okay, he was just testing it out.
He gave you money, didn't he?
Only after I begged!
Well... He wasn't gonna give me if I didn't ask for it.
Do you know it's even... Well, you have to consider that he actually gave you money.
No people would do that in this server.
You don't understand.
Oh, really?
Really?
Not... Yeah.
That's so fucked up.
Oh yeah, what's an erper?
People were asking me if I was an erper.
What's an erper?
How do you spell that?
I don't know.
They're like, are you an erper?
And I was like, I just got here.
Are you talking about ERP-er?
Wait, did he... Oh, was it cause I was naked?
Yeah, no.
Um, there's people who ERP on this server.
What?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Oh, it's because I was naked on a horse.
Oh no.
I just wanted help.
I didn't want an erotic roleplay.
Don't look at him.
He's... he's...
He's just passing the torture room.
Wait, wait.
Oh.
Don't look at him.
Don't look over there.
I thought you said these people are...
What is wrong?
Good morning.
Oh, that scared me.
Oh, wait.
Is that a taxi?
Yeah.
What else is there?
Come here.
Who me?
Can you pay for my taxi service?
I need to show you someone.
Come here!
Hi, Noah.
This is my friend named Doki.
She just joined today.
I'm trying to convince her to join this kingdom because it's the safest one.
Well, yeah.
It's definitely the safest one.
Oh, wow.
Kumi gave me a guitar.
Now I'm here busking for scraps.
Bye-bye.
Oh, scraps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Each note is like one scrap.
And you're willingly listening to it.
Oh, thank you, sir!
Wait.
I'm enjoying.
Oh, you're back!
Please, I'm so poor.
Kumi, please.
Do I have to buy it somewhere?
I'm so poor.
Pick it up off the floor.
That's fucked up.
Do you want another one?
Yes, yes.
Pick it up off the floor.
That's so fucked up.
You gave me what?
How much did Foolish give you?
What the fuck?
Pick it up off the floor.
Alright.
You want more?
Yeah.
Yes, I do.
I don't have a gambling problem because I never started it.
Wait, can you take me to the casino?
Oh, I gambled.
Wait.
Wait, do you know where the casino is?
That's cool.
No, I don't.
Uh, yeah, but...
Everyone knows where the casino is, Doki.
Not me.
I don't know if I can really head there because...
I have a thing I gotta do.
Yeah, wait.
Where is it?
People are gonna be waiting on me.
So, the casino is at the very tippy top of the map in the safe zone.
Oh!
That's where you were earlier.
Where P2 was?
Yeah, it was up there.
The most away it could be.
Oh my god.
It's that far?
I thought there were multiple casinos.
There's... I know like another one...
somewhere.
Where...
It's also in the north.
What the fuck?
Why are they all in one area?
Uh, I want to see a man named Trousy.
Oh.
Alright, where are we going next?
Where are we going next?
Which way?
Do you want free stuff?
Yes.
Okay.
There's people on the other side.
Doki wants to join the kingdom.
She's already a can.
You said that if you want to join the kingdom, you surely can.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay, so you're...
Noah, do you like how I look?
Um...
Is that like a...
Oh, wow, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, you're repairing.
I was like, why are you shitting his car?
I feel so unsafe right now.
Um...
Actually, I haven't seen that hat yet.
That's a fun one.
How did you get it?
How did you get that?
You have to be there.
I have to be there.
It's like an Easter special item.
Oh.
Bye, Noah.
I love you.
Bye.
Thanks for the scraps.
Have a good, safe trip.
Oh, you're very welcome.
I hope you can get a terrible gambling addiction soon.
Thank you.
I hope so, too.
Oh.
Have a look at that.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
All right.
Wait, we can gamble here.
Wait, we can gamble.
It won't be the same.
It won't be the same, though.
Okay, you want me to take you to the casino?
Yes!
I want...
Wait, no, what are the other places?
Casino should be the last place.
So, I can beg for other people to donate.
I can teach you how to get more money.
Okay, yeah.
I should celebrate by gambling.
There's people under us, down south, that you can probably beg for money from.
These are nice people?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, let's go.
It's time for the grift, yeah.
Okay.
Do your thing where you play a song and say, you have to pay up.
If not, you're going to cry.
You have to kill them a little.
You know what?
That sounds doable.
I hear people.
Alright, introduce me as a new person.
Hi!
Look, this is my friend.
She just joined today.
It's her first day ever playing Rust.
Yeah, I've never been here.
I've never done this before.
Hello guys!
Look, I got my friend to start playing today.
I gave her a guitar.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you guys like this music?
I just learned it today.
Love it.
Yeah, it's like one note per scratch.
Oh, it's going up!
More notes are being played now!
I hope you guys are rich!
I don't think they're processing.
It's too noisy.
You're going to have to say, okay, that was 50 scraps.
Okay, alright, that was 50 scraps.
Can we ask you a question?
Did you tell your friend?
I guess you're paying for the group, right?
Are you going to pay for the group?
I only have beans.
Doki, look at the Doki Dog!
I'll show you what a scrap is.
I do!
Oh my god!
Look!
Wait, you made this?
I like it!
Oh, that's so cute!
Guys, I got a can of beans for my payment.
Thank you.
Is that enough?
Do you think that's enough?
I might turn into two scraps.
Come check out more art!
Come inside!
Oh!
Wait, did you all draw this?
Holy shit!
Wait, Doki, you don't understand.
It's so fucking hard to draw in this game.
I know, I know!
That's why I'm like, what the fuck?
Holy shit!
There is 500 scraps buried in this location on the map.
Wait, there is?
Where is this?
Oh my god, we have to go!
We have to go and find it, Gumi!
You don't recognize this?
Oh my god!
Gumi!
We have to find it!
That's 500 dollars!
Oh wait, I'm dehydrated.
Drink your water bottle, you do.
You have to hold it in your hand.
Okay.
I'm learning.
Oh my god, dog with gun!
Dog with gun?
Hahaha!
I did this.
Okay, but you said dog with gun.
Hahaha!
Okay.
You said I need to find out what you did?
That's really good.
Wow, fox with gun!
Fox with gun!
Wait, how do you play?
On B, and then you can smoke.
B?
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, fox with gun!
Oh my god, smith!
What the fuck!
The smith!
Yeah, I like this one.
This one's my favorite.
What the fuck, they do actual art?
Yeah, this is crazy!
Gumi, that's you!
That's me!
That's you!
Oh my god, Da Vinci!
Da Vinci was in the Rust server?
Who's Da Vinci?
I knew, I knew.
I knew he was alive.
Oh hey, a horse.
That one's a really good horse too.
He's pretty much alive, yes.
And still painting.
Wait, you're Da Vinci?
No, no, no.
Da Vinci is Da Vinci.
Wait, what did you do?
Which one's your art?
I am Monstera.
These are my works.
Oh my god, you did that?
Oh my god, you know what?
You're better than Da Vinci, holy shit.
That shit...
Honestly?
No wonder Da Vinci's dead.
You're so much better.
He knew you were about to be born.
Oh, okay.
This one's my favorite.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, fish!
Where's the gun?
No gun, they're on vacation.
Yeah, where's the gun?
I think it could've been...
9 out of 10, missing a gun, not gonna lie.
The dude's just having fun.
They're on vacation.
Don't forget, I found a photo of you!
Wait, what?
I'm the rat!
That's me!
You're the rat?
That's you!
That's me!
I found you too!
You're over here at the bottom!
Oh my god, that's me!
That's you!
That's me!
You're very good.
That's so amazing.
Oh my god, dog!
What gun?
Oh my god, there you are, 10 out of 10.
I put a helmet on the rat, guys.
10 out of 10.
Look, look.
I put a helmet on the rat.
Oh my god!
That is ridiculous.
It's you!
It's us!
That's us!
He's ready for war.
Can I get a T-Stick?
I wanna add mine.
Yes, yes.
He's trying dogs and guns and do they take commissions?
Someone in my chat, there you go.
It's Monstera.
She keeps drawing dogs with guns.
It's so good though.
It sucks.
Just try drawing in Rust as well.
I can craft you a couple of canvases if you like.
Oh, that would be great.
Yeah.
Oh my god, can I be part of this art gallery?
Draw a dog with a gun.
Yeah, I can auth you on this gallery.
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
Gumi, we can be part of this art gallery!
We're gonna be famous!
Just like her!
My favorite art chart.
Dog with gun.
I'll place a couple of canvases around.
Oh, nice!
Yay!
See, Doki, they're so nice.
They give you free stuff.
Oh my god, we're gonna be part of this art gallery!
I'm done.
Let's see.
Oh my god, we're gonna be part of history!
It's a sunshine.
Oh, I see Heavy!
This way!
I found a new person to scam!
Wait, wait, wait.
But they're gonna give us our canvases though!
Oh, you're right!
Yeah, we should get our canvases first.
It's close enough, okay?
It's actually green.
It's like greenish yellow.
No, no, it's good.
It's fine.
Oh, there's a sun!
Yeah, there's a sun!
It's perfect.
Can you put some shine onto it?
A.K.A.
Repaint everything I just did.
We should tell them we're leaving though, right?
Yeah, no, I was just parking the car closer.
Oh, okay.
Parking the car!
We're so civilized.
I'm not gonna lie, this is really my favorite half an hour of the entire song.
Wait, who's that?
Hello.
Hi, I'm Valerie.
Oh!
I got my friend to join.
This is her first day on.
Yeah, yeah, this is my first day on.
That's her right there!
You like the song?
Yeah, I'm having a great time!
She gave me a guitar.
She's my favorite.
Yeah?
Oh, yeah!
By the way, it's one scrap per note.
So I hope you have the money.
Oh, um, yeah.
I became Beth out of nowhere.
Bro, I thought you...
Did he say he was gonna give you a scrap?
Bro, he ran away!
You said we can scam him!
I thought you said he was a chump!
I think...
I think he ran out of money himself, actually.
No!
You told me he was a chump!
He was a chump, Goomy!
I thought he was a chump, too.
Yeah.
Oh my go- What the fuck happened?!
What the- Bro, what?!
What the hell happened?!
What the fu- How did that- What?!
We left for like five seconds!
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's back to normal.
Oh, yay.
I was like, oh my god!
You did that in five seconds?!
I can grow up so fast!
I have some art questions.
Just added a couple of details.
If you make a painting, can you pick it up?
She's getting art advice.
Oh!
Put it somewhere else, or does it- Oh my god, this is truly an artwork.
RTX is so good.
I'm so happy.
I was like, bro, what the fuck?!
We got lit for like five seconds!
We gotta go.
We got magical curses and shit.
Wait, what?!
I can give you a couple.
I actually have them.
Oh, thank you!
I'm enjoying the art gallery.
I'll get the cake here.
I'll bring you to press the button.
Or you can press the button in the top left once we get in the castle.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Woah, a bar?!
Wait, a bar?!
Oh shit, is there people there?!
Move!
Oh my god!
I'm open.
Oh!
Oh, they're just photos.
They're just photos!
Yeah.
Oh my god, there's a furry in the server.
Look.
Look at that.
Who are these guys?
Oh, I can make you one of those.
Who are these guys though?
Wait, who are they?
I don't know them by name.
Who are they?
You don't know everybody in the server?
Dude, you and I look exactly the same once I take this hat off.
No, but he has a wolf head on.
So they must be special.
I can make you one of those if you want them.
I want a wolf head?
They'll think I'm wild.
You gotta go home then.
Yeah!
Okay, nice.
You like the way I open that door?
Yeah, I like you.
Watch this.
AHHHHH!
You're so strong.
I'm so strong.
I know, right?
Look at that.
All those guitar playing has like, buffed me up.
Oh.
Yeah.
Over to our right is the swimming pool.
We have pool parties there.
Oh my god, I wanna check out the swimming pool.
Oh my god.
Look, you can...
Wait.
You can drive this shit around too.
Wait, there's a naked guy here.
Who the fuck is this guy?
He's sleeping.
Can you like, accidentally kill him?
Yeah, but people don't do that in this kingdom.
Maybe in the other kingdoms.
But will they know if you kill them?
Yeah, it says it on them.
It says you were killed by blank with blank.
Guess it's just a nice relaxing day.
Oh my god, how do you...
Bump.
Yay!
Oh my god, this is the good life.
Being taken care of by Gumi.
I got a guitar.
I'm begging for scraps.
The good life.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm running out of food.
I'm ready.
While rust is more peaceful than rumber...
This is the good king...
Guys, this is the chill kingdom right now.
We're not in the...
Literally the first minute of being in the server...
I got ran over by S-fan.
Like...
While I was on a horse, guys.
And shot at.
And shot at too.
We got shot at while we were driving here.
We're just in a kingdom that's like, peaceful.
I'm telling you, it's a gated community.
It is a gated community.
Guys, we're literally...
We're literally in a gated community, guys.
Like...
Okay, right after this, I'm gonna take you...
Yeah?
To learn how to get money.
Oh, cool.
Easily and fast.
Wait, does acquire work?
A tiny bit.
Oh, just a tiny bit?
I like that.
I like those odds.
Hello...
Oh, I'm gonna be in the house.
I hope Abe's not around.
Yay!
I get to be in the house!
Here, you can watch that...
Make sure it doesn't burn.
Okay.
How do I know if it's not burning?
I'll make you your wolf head.
You'll just know.
How do I know?
Oh, I might look at it.
Okay.
Which one is the...
Oh, here you go.
Oh, got some...
Careful, there's gunshots outside.
It's okay, we're safe inside.
Alright, I made it for you.
Yay!
Oh my god, is there tiger heads too?
No.
There's no tigers here.
There's no tigers in Rust?
Put it on.
Oh my god.
How do I put this on?
Oh!
Now I definitely look wild.
Now I look like a hermit.
A hermit for real.
Busting for scraps.
Oh hey, that is your art.
Did you draw that?
No, my friend drew me that.
That's so cute.
Yup.
Alright, I got some meat.
Oh, I should eat.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
I keep forgetting how to press the button.
There you go.
I'm full now.
Oh, I think I need more water.
I ran out.
I have a water tank outside.
Okay.
Which one of you pickle muncher stole goomy scrap from the hot box?
Oh yeah.
Fucking Abe stole my scrap.
What?
But he's the admin.
He can literally spawn scrap.
He just...
Here, this is the water tank.
Press E on it.
Where is it?
Outside.
Oh.
Can I fill it up?
Oh, take.
Oh, I see.
How much... what's the maximum I can take?
250, I think.
Oh, okay.
Let's drink some now then.
Let's fill it up.
You know what?
I'll make you a sleeping bag or two.
Yay!
Can I sleep outside your house?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Guys.
I'll let you even sleep in my garage.
Oh my god.
Guys.
I'm not mooching off of goomy, guys.
Well...
Oh my god.
I get to sleep.
I'm not squatting, guys.
She's just helping a friend in need.
I'm that friend.
No longer...
Guys, I'm no longer homeless.
I gotta sleep in goomy's garage.
Where the hell is my car?
Put it on the other side.
I wanna be careful.
It gets really darn dark out here.
What happens when it's dark?
Oh, it's impossible to see shit.
Oh, okay.
I was like, is there anything I should be worried about?
Guys, I can't believe it.
Wait, what the fuck is on fire?
Yeah, that's one of the cars that I could fix up.
Oh.
So it's like the spawn rate and stuff.
I'm getting on.
You really enjoy my music?
Yeah.
I call this...
Scraps.
For hire.
Alright.
Yay.
Can I please...
I'm gonna put your sleeping bag at the very tippy top.
Okay.
On top of the house?
Wait, it's not even gonna be inside?
Girl, if it's inside and I'm not on to let you out, you might get...
Oh.
What happened to me?
I don't know.
What was that sound?
If I'm not here to let you out...
Yeah, but you can just tell me the code.
I don't think I can do that.
Why not?
You don't trust me?
You know, after everything we've been through...
You just give me...
But it's...
It's not like I can trust you.
It's so cold outside.
It's so cold and...
And like, what if...
What if they get me?
What if the bandits get me?
What, you're gonna sleep outside with me?
What are you doing?
I'm giving you the bag.
I can...
I can just spawn you anywhere.
Oh.
Yay!
I'm giving you multiple respawn points.
Oh!
Yay.
Yay!
Give to friend...
Don't...
Okay.
You have multiple respawn points now.
Yay!
Is that too bad?
Yeah.
I mean, I get to see the stars too.
And you live in a...
Pretty much safer area.
Yeah!
I feel so safe.
We should head to Team Rocket's area.
I've been told...
I've been told that there's turns outside.
Oh.
Like, they shoot you upon rolling up.
What?
But like, what if I'm naked?
No, like it doesn't matter if you're not on the list.
Oh.
If I'm not on the list?
What's it called?
You have to be on their TC list.
Their automatic list.
Or else they'll automatically shoot anyone who's not on the list.
What the fuck?
Bro!
Mendo like DM'd me and was like, If you need help, I can assign a pro player to help you in Rust.
Like, I'm joking!
Yeah, they're...
They got agents and shit.
They're scary over there.
Bro, they got like pro players on their team.
Oh, HotNic and Chelsea are pro players too.
Wait, really?
Oh, nice.
The ones we just met in Arching them?
Oh, the one that built the torture chambers?
Yeah, they're the pro players.
Oh!
I played with them in Rust Rivals.
You should see how crazy they go.
Oh, jeez.
I mean, they fucking built a torture chamber.
So like, I already could tell how crazy they go.
Yeah.
Oh shit, xQc is their leader?
Oh, that makes sense.
He will take your scrap.
Oh, no.
I heard he has a gambling problem.
But like, in game as well.
Oh, no.
That's crazy.
Oh, man.
Um...
Yeah.
I'm scared that you'll take my scrap.
Alright, what should we do?
Well, it's nighttime now, so it's a bit scary.
But...
Yeah?
I can try.
You can try what?
Here, maybe I'll take you in one of my safer cars.
Okay.
Wait, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Can you protect me for a sec?
And entertain my chat?
I'll get inside.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
How do I get in?
Let me back up a little.
You better get out of the way.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, I can tell you a story again.
Oh...
You guys love when I tell you stories from my childhood.
Um...
Oh, man.
Last time I told you guys to...
Being on the floor rat story.
What story?
What story can I tell you this time?
You guys know the dick sucking trees story.
We can get in together.
Um...
Oh, you guys still know about the dick-sucking tree story?
No, you guys know about it.
Um...
I can tell you about how there were people...
So in my high school...
Since, you know, I went to an art high school and everything...
There were people who would have sex in the bushes.
Oh, welcome back.
She back?
She just moved.
Okay, anyways...
So, because it was an art high school, we had soundproof rooms and everything.
But we also had people who would like...
Have sex in bushes or under the staircases...
Or in the soundproof rooms in our high school.
And...
It was kind of freaky.
Cause like, sometimes I would take naps in the soundproof rooms.
Cause I would have an off period.
But then I realized people would be fucking in there.
So I got really uncomfortable and I stopped taking naps.
And I was like, I'm not gonna take naps in there.
Um...
Well, you guys know, but there was a glory hole on the third floor girl's bathroom.
That was pretty cool.
That was the nicest bathroom too.
Which makes sense why there would be a glory hole there.
I have a photo of it.
If you guys want.
Um...
Hmm...
Honestly...
I really wanted to go...
Get breakfast.
Which is one roasted sweet potato.
Or one roasted yam.
But Doki left me in charge of you guys.
So I have to keep talking.
What the fuck?
Why are they saying, Doki please help us?
What did you do?
I told them more stories from my childhood.
What?
What stories did you tell them?
About my high school.
Oh, oh okay.
I have, okay.
Yeah, her high school was fucking wild.
Guys.
Here, do you know what?
Eat this.
Is this?
Oh.
Yay!
Where are we going next?
I'm gonna go.
Do you know what?
It's your turn.
Except I'm not streaming.
So you have to entertain your chat while I go get a yam.
Okay.
Alright guys.
Okay guys.
What did Gumi tell you guys about her high school?
Because she has a lot of high school stories.
Some of the stories she might have told you.
I don't even know about.
Okay.
Where did I tell, 2 told, what?
Oh, is it the tree?
Is it the tree?
Oh, yeah.
That's a classic Gumi story.
The tree is a classic Gumi story.
Yeah.
Yeah, her school is fucking wild.
I went to international school because that was less wild.
Like, it was so.
Okay, so like my international school, it was like super wild.
We're like... I didn't learn the word fuck until maybe like eighth grade because people were like, oh my god, she said fuck.
So like in our school, we're like, oh my god, she said... and we would look around like fuck.
Good heavens!
Poor Doki!
We were very innocent people there.
We were so innocent.
What the fuck?
She said what?
Oh my god, a bad word?
I'm enjoying touring the rest... I definitely don't think I could have done this by myself.
The Rust server by myself, like walking around.
I would have definitely died.
Multiple times if I didn't have a tour guide and I was exploring it myself because I feel like I...
What Kumi told me... people here are definitely not kind.
People here are not nice people.
So I'm glad I had a tour guide.
I'm glad I like...
I love asking them to give me a tour.
Because I would have like not known what to do.
It's Rust.
Oh no!
I came in late!
Like that's the worst part.
I came in here late.
So I don't like...
I'm fucking... I was naked.
Someone thought I was an ERP-er because I was naked and on a horse.
Things were not on my side there.
And I thought like I could be that person.
I was like, hey guys, I'm new.
I have no money.
And I'm new.
Uh...
Can you like, you know, treat me well?
And then I got ran over by a car.
I was like, hey guys!
And then I literally got ran over by a car.
While I was on my horse.
It truly was insane.
Oh no, my fucking torch.
No!
My source of light!
It's okay.
Is there a way to play music that's not just these chords?
How do I play like...
Um...
Different notes on the guitar?
Oh yeah, and then I stole two horses too.
One of them died to the car.
Is there a way to play different notes?
Can you set up MIDI?
What the fuck is MIDI?
What the fuck?
That's keyboard capture.
What did you...
What did you make me do?
I pressed R.
What?
Oh my god!
What is keyboard capture?
Oh, never mind.
I don't know.
I don't know what I did.
Someone said press R.
Press um...
Your keyboard...
Number pad.
Oh!
I see.
I was like thinking if there's like a way to play other music.
But I don't have...
I don't have like a numpad.
You can rebind it right now.
No, that's fine.
That's way too much work.
What the hell?
It's okay.
I know this one song is good enough.
Alright, where are you gonna take me?
Gumi is processing.
She's eating her yam right now.
Yeah.
Um...
Is it daytime yet?
I think so.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Let's go.
Oh, is that the other safer car?
Yeah, this is a safer car.
How long did it take you to build that?
Not very long.
I just had to fix it up.
And put new parts in.
Since we're like...
You know, I'm like the trophy wife.
Does that mean like it's our car?
Huh?
This ain't no one's car but mine.
What?
I didn't sign a prenup.
Hey, I'll get you your own car.
I'll get my own car?
Mm-hmm.
Oh my god.
I'm the trophy wife, guys.
I get my own car.
I'm gonna get my Gucci bag and my Louis Vuitton.
With my...
With my sugar daddy's credit card.
It's all on Goomy, guys.
Even Super Chats, guys.
All Super Chats are gonna be on Goomy's credit card.
What?
What the hell is an Octa Super?
Oh, darling.
That's just like one dollar.
You can sit in the back too if you want.
There's beds in the back.
How do I sit in the back?
Just lift.
Get out.
And then...
It says Kiko.
Oh.
Here.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I feel so safe.
Yeah, there's actually one of the safer cars.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can open stuff?
Why am I open?
What is this?
Oh, like a barbecue.
Oh my god.
We can barbecue back here?
That's so comfy.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get some car parts real quick.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm living it.
Road trip.
Woo!
Wait, where are we heading to?
Oh my god!
Goomy, they're using your credit card right now.
Man, thank you for using Goomy's credit card.
Free Supas?
Yeah!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Wait, why did I get a text from my bank?
Don't worry about it.
What?
Nothing.
I just heard some gunshots.
Oh, that's alright.
We're safe here.
They wouldn't shoot this car.
I have a gun too.
I can aim.
Well, Mendo and them might.
Oh, wait.
No, they won't.
They won't.
I'll be like, don't shoot us.
It's Doki and Goomy.
You wouldn't shoot us, right?
We came from Overwatch.
Yeah, they just have to hear you first.
If I yell loud enough, they'll hear me.
Don't worry.
Wood can stop gunshots.
I learned that in science.
Alright.
So here, I'm going to show you something real quick.
Get out of the car.
Yeah?
Yeah.
So right here, you know that mace I gave you?
Yeah?
Hit the barrel with the mace.
Oh, okay.
Whoa!
Oh my god, that was one whole scrap.
Yeah, press E in this.
No, that's not it.
The box is you have to press E on.
Okay.
What about these?
No.
It's only the barrels.
Like over here too.
Wait, where are you?
Where did you go?
Across the street.
Wait, you went across the street?
How?
Wait, where did you go?
Across the other street, man.
I'm very colorful.
It's hard to miss.
Oh, shit.
Scraps.
Mm-hmm.
So, if you want to go scrap farming...
Yeah?
You can take a car with you and keep driving.
The scrap thingies only appear on the road.
Uh-huh.
Sorry, I want to sit in the front now.
Won't be here.
Oh my god, thank you for the Akasufa ritual, Gumi!
Thank you!
Oh.
They're all using your credit card!
It's on her!
Isn't she sweet, guys?
Oh my god, next she's gonna give me a Louis Vuitton bag.
Guys, this latest Louis Vuitton bag, Gucci shoes, Versace.
What a pretty!
Oh.
Yay!
Wait, is this part of it?
Yeah, the red ones specifically only have oil in them.
Oh, okay.
For the cars, right?
Mm-hmm.
Is this a restaurant?
Oh, is anybody in here?
No, nobody's in here.
How's anybody gonna fucking eat in this town?
The restaurant's not open.
You have to learn how to cook for yourself, man.
Myself?
By the way, look at the cars on the road and tell me if you want any of them.
Oh, okay.
I'll get you any new car you want.
Oh my god, thanks, Trigger Daddy!
Anything for you, kitten.
Thanks, darling!
Oh my... guys!
Guys, I'm gonna get a car!
I'm gonna get Ferrari, guys!
Oh my god, I'm gonna get a Tesla!
I want a Tesla!
Watch it.
We're in Oklahoma.
That doesn't exist here.
But I want a Tesla!
What are we doing here?
So, right here...
Yeah?
There's more boxes and stuff inside this supermarket and there's free food, too.
Oh!
For free?
Uh-huh.
If you look in the green boxes around there...
The green boxes?
They should be on the shelves.
Oh, okay.
Alright, let's see.
Green boxes...
I see pickles!
Oh yeah, don't eat those.
Oh.
Well, you could, but there's like a...
A chance that you might throw up.
Oh.
Wait, where are... I don't think there's any boxes here.
Oh, here.
I don't see anything.
I just see like, empty...
Um...
I think it got looted.
Oh.
Maybe someone ate it all already.
Yeah, someone else was hungry.
So, the stores refresh...
Every few minutes.
So...
Sometimes when you're going up the street and you come back...
Somebody was here three minutes ago.
I said every few minutes, man.
Oh.
Okay, come here.
Where's here?
Come to the back, where the cars parked.
Yeah?
Come in here.
What did you get in here?
Oh.
Press E on this?
Yeah.
And the random useless objects you get, like...
Stop signs that say scrap or whatever, or like...
Beans?
Yeah, beans.
You can right click and put it in there.
Oh, okay.
Then turn on...
Propane metal, tank, sheet metal.
Yeah.
Well, you have to put in input.
Oh.
Make sure you eat the beans first too.
Oh, okay.
And then sheet metal.
Metal blade.
Should I put the metal blade there too?
You can, yeah.
You'll get plenty of those.
Turning on.
How long does it take?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, fragments.
61 metal fragments?
What do I do with the fragments?
So that could be used to fix up your car.
Oh!
Or to craft stuff.
That's a lot.
What's the rope for?
I could put the rope too.
That's also for crafting stuff.
Yeah, I'm gonna put stuff in there.
So if it doesn't process with the stuff you put in there, that means it can't be...
Okay.
I got stuff.
Here you go.
Here.
Oh my god, more scraps!
Rich!
Um...
Oh, you can throw stuff.
You can pick whatever is spawning in here.
Where did my mace go?
I actually threw it.
Girl, I don't know where you threw your mace.
Where did my mace...
Kumi, I lost my mace!
Yeah, I don't know where you threw that thing.
Kumi!
Oh, it's here.
I got it.
Yeah!
14 more scraps.
Oh my god, I'm rich!
I'm rich!
There you go, kitten.
Yeah!
Get in.
Of course.
I feel so pampered, guys.
I'm learning!
Now I'm gonna take you to the casino, okay?
The casino?
You know the gun I gave you?
Yeah.
I'm gonna take you to the casino.
Don't take it out when you're in the casino or in that area.
Oh, because they'll shoot me?
Uh-huh.
Okay, I'm gonna put that away.
All right.
Yay!
We're gonna gamble, guys!
We're gonna gamble all of Kumi's money away!
What?
And we're gonna win!
Mm-hmm.
We're gonna win money!
Oh my gosh, this is a huge map.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Where are we?
Holy sh- hey, that's where I died.
So all the way down there is team- what the fuck?
What's the debris field?
The what?
The debris field on Team Rocket area.
Oh, hey, they have a taxi service!
Oh, yeah.
A lot of places have taxi service.
There's a lot up here.
There's a lot up here, too.
Oh my god.
How much is it?
Oh my god, I should have made you a telephone before we left.
Oh, wait, yeah.
I wanna call- I could make you a cell phone so you can call me anytime in-game.
Wait!
There's lots of scraps in these.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go ahead, go get him.
Oh, okay.
No, wait, right here.
Okay.
I'll grab the scraps.
You're the one that's gram- gambling, man.
I guess I'll lift a finger.
I guess.
Oh, Shay, there's a goggles!
What's this?
A spinning siren light?
How do I put that?
Ooh, I wanna wear- You have to put it on your house or car or whatever.
Wait!
Can I put it on your car?
Go in!
Get in!
I'm scared.
I'm so scared!
That was Iron Mouser's Kingdom, and notice how we got shot at right away?
Yeah!
That was- That was a little scary.
No one does that around the rusty bone.
The rusty- Woah, what's that over there to our left?
You see that?
Oh, the left?
Yeah, it didn't fully spawn in yet but it was like fire and stuff.
That might have been Ironmount's castle.
That's her castle?
Oh my god, it has fire.
Wait, are the castles like custom to each land?
They're all the same castle.
Oh, I see.
I wonder like...
Woah.
I'm surprised we haven't met anybody new.
Oh hey, there's another bear.
I'm surprised there's nobody new here.
So this right here...
Yeah?
Is the gas station.
You can also recycle stuff back in the...
Oh, I see.
I see.
I'm getting a little thirsty.
Stay hydrated everybody.
Don't worry.
I'll turn on the radio for us.
If you look on the right hand side, that's the coliseum.
Woah!
What's going on in the coliseum?
I don't know.
Maybe we should check it out.
It's on the other side.
We should check it out.
I wanna watch.
Okay, go ahead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
I'll drop you off here.
Wait, are you not coming with me?
Gumi?
Go.
I'll get back in the car if you know what's good for you.
But it's a coliseum.
What's the worst that could happen?
They're not fighting in the coliseum.
There's no guns allowed in the coliseum.
So those are wild people fighting.
Oh.
Coliseum leaderboard.
No, they're fighting in here.
What, are they?
Yeah.
There's like people fighting in here.
People are dead in here too.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
I'll wait for you out here.
Like, why is there a dead body here?
How do I like watch?
Oh, is everybody watching here?
There's no way you got full HP on that.
I was 65.
Okay, I'll be honest.
Is your clothes over there?
Yeah.
You got clothing and stuff on you?
They might shoot you.
Oh.
Oh, I'm dead.
Sorry about that.
Okay, let's try...
You're gonna believe.
Okay, I'm coming back.
There's a bear outside!
Okay.
I'm coming.
I'm coming back.
Where are you?
I'm on the road.
Where's my Goomy taxi?
At the top of M5.
You're gonna have to go to M5.
Hold G now.
M5?
Where am I?
Oh, oh.
Oh my god, I think I see you.
You're parked over there.
I saw like, uh, Snuffy, Fluffy, uh...
Uh...
Guys, who was over there, guys?
Chat, who did we see?
I don't know if they're good players or nice players.
What's that?
Someone's chopping trees near us.
Wait, let's say hi to them.
They could be nice people.
Yeah...
Why can't we say hi to them?
Oh, Sneezy was there.
Who the fuck is Sneezy?
I feel like you're naming...
Snow White, no...
Yeah, so yeah, there you go, Snuffy, Fluffy.
Yeah, there's... oh wait.
Here we are.
Oh, is this gambling time?
Is it Gamba?
Oh my god!
Which one's the best casino to Gamba?
Wait, it's the...
It's over here.
Where are you?
That's Chris... or is it over here?
Hi Chris!
Hello!
Hi Gumi.
Hi!
Okay.
What's the best place to gamble?
Right here...
You can bet on a wheel by sitting on the couch and sitting...
No, this is the Gamba wheel.
...and there's a machine on the side.
Oh!
Hello?
Wait, come over here.
Wait, where are you?
Yeah?
There's also slots here.
Oh!
Okay, what does it hit so far?
There's also blackjack.
Blackjack?
Um...
Poker.
Wait, let's play poker.
Girl, I gave you all my scraps so you can gamble.
Wait, I can give you one.
I'm going to Miami.
I don't want it.
You ready?
Go.
Here, sit here.
Okay, okay.
Is it on the couch?
Okay.
Oh, dude.
If this hits, we're going to Miami.
You see that machine on your left?
Yeah.
It's open.
Virgin margarita.
Strawberry.
You can put scraps...
You can split them up, by the way.
How do I split them up?
Click it in your inventory.
And then on the top, it'll have this little bar you can drag around to split it.
And then you grab it from the box.
Oh!
I almost...
I almost grabbed a lot.
Wait, how the fuck?
Wait, how do I split it?
Oh, I got it!
Okay.
I put 30...
I put 3 in yellow.
Nice.
And then you watch the wheel to see what it lands on.
Oh, yo.
All right.
It better land on...
It should land on yellow, right?
It landed on blue.
No!
It's okay.
I only gambled 3.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I got this.
Okay.
Let's leave with that one.
We're winners.
I'll put 12 here.
And then I'll put 10 on red.
I'm ready.
Wait, we should sit in the center.
Sit in the center.
All right.
Wait, wait, that's my money.
Wait.
Does the money not come with me?
No.
Wait!
Okay.
It's okay.
I only put a little bit.
All right.
Okay.
Blue and then red.
I can't believe it.
I got robbed before I even gambled.
You better learn.
You better learn fast.
I'm learning.
All right.
Big money.
Come on.
No!
I won.
Did you lose all your money?
She stole my money and then I lost all my money.
I gave her.
I gave you all that money.
No, that's not true.
Let's get this straight.
I've scavenged some of them in the road.
You scavenged 10, man.
You scavenged 10, you know.
I played music for scrap.
I worked so hard for it.
I learned how to play the guitar for that scrap.
All right.
Pick it up.
It's on the floor.
Oh, my God.
Woah woah woah woah woah!
Yay!
Okay, I should win now.
There's no way.
How could I lose?
Luck would be on my side.
Come on!
Purple!
Did I put purple and blue?
I don't even remember what I put.
Purple and blue!
Come on!
You won?
You won money?
Okay, look.
This is it.
I would hit it big.
The moment it hits purple or blue...
It's over.
The moment it hits purple or blue, I win everything back.
I can't hit yellows like three times in a row.
There's no way.
Look at the wheel and look at the probability.
Yeah, but like...
It can't always hit yellow.
That's true.
There's no way.
That's why I didn't bet on yellow this time.
Wait.
But you won money.
Oh, this time.
No.
Come on.
Purple, blue!
I got it.
Oh, this.
Oh, yes!
I did it!
Wow.
Wait how much did I win?
I won 54?
I almost won back everything.
Nine.
Oh my God.
So, this is how gambling edition starts.
Yeah.
I feel just like XQC.
Let's see.
It has to be purple now.
And then I'll put like one...
I'll put two on red just in case.
Oh my god.
Wait, why don't you gamble more?
I am gambling.
I know, but like...
Why don't you just spend your days here instead?
Yeah, you never lose unless you keep going.
If you always keep going.
You never lose if...
Does Christopher E say here the entire time?
Because he's like rank three in gambling.
Maybe.
Does he live here?
I feel like he spends majority of his time...
Wait.
Did I blue?
No, you got one again!
Blue!
Oh my god, 54 again.
Oh my god, I am winning big money right now.
Blue.
Oh my god, I'm actually winning big money.
I'll put one in red.
Yeah, I'll put...
I'll put two in red as well.
I made money.
I'm doing it.
Yeah, see?
This is great.
I'm gonna cut up my scrap back later.
Wait, what?
What?
But you're already rich.
You're...
You're already...
You're the god.
You saw the sign.
Abe takes my money when I'm asleep.
You're a god though, but he's an admin.
Just ask for more money from him.
Oh.
Come on, purple, blue, purple, blue, purple, blue.
Or red!
Come on!
Big money, big money!
Big money!
Play my...
No!
Blue?
Yeah!
Blue is hot!
Blue is hot now!
Yes!
I think Chris Berge lost all his money.
He's leaving.
Oh my god!
Wait, did he lose all his money?
Maybe.
Oh my god!
I got...
I'm like...
I have a profit!
I actually have a profit!
I can never lose.
Guys, I actually can never lose, guys.
Holy shit.
I put more in.
I think my...
I think playing music is giving us good luck.
I think so.
Blue is insane though.
Blue...
Blue is actually big money town.
I never lose.
zi Wait, what are we doing after the casino?
I don't know!
Up to you.
Ironmouse.
Hang on, my turn to choose the correct translation.
Who's in the OTK kingdom?
Wait, red?
Oh, no.
No!!
RAMAMOW!
I REALLY GOT CUT OFF TO ALREADY WILLING TO RUN FOR K traditions!
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done.
I'm done gambling.
I learned a lesson.
It's time to stop.
Quit while you're ahead, guys.
There's like towns, right?
In between the kingdoms?
Okay, do you want to visit Ironmouse's kingdom?
Or one of the towns that you passed by earlier?
Oh, I want to visit one of the towns we passed by earlier.
I want to see the locals.
The savages outside the kingdoms.
I don't know if they're on right now.
Do you want that car?
Remember, you have to look at cars that you want too.
Which one?
That car in the middle of the street.
There's a car in the middle of the street?
Oh, this one?
It's armored.
It's an armored car.
Oh, yeah, I like that car.
Yeah, it's armored.
I want it.
How do I see it in that car?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's fixing it.
How do I see out of it?
You remember how you hit that red barrel earlier?
Yeah.
Oh, I feel it.
I'll put it in.
Give me one second.
I'll put this in.
I'll teach you.
So, come to the back of the car.
Yeah.
See this red box?
Put it in there.
I did though.
Okay.
It wouldn't let me.
Oh, I need a different fuel.
Mine's like crude oil.
Oh.
I'll put some in.
Oh, low grade fuel.
That's called low grade.
Come here.
Yeah.
This side.
How do you see?
Oh, here.
Wait.
Give me something.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
What?
Here you go.
Okay.
Maybe I chose the wrong car.
Too late.
I already used my stuff to fix it.
That's your car now.
Why did you encourage me to get this car?
Okay.
Let's go driving together.
I can't even.
Okay.
It'll be okay.
And those little pixels.
I can see where they're at.
Okay.
This was a mistake.
And here's the town.
The local town.
Is anybody here in the local town?
No.
Most people log on at night.
Oh.
It's not nighttime.
It's like 2.44.
I know.
That's why I said most people log on at night.
Oh, wait.
There's somebody here.
Hi.
Hello.
Hey there.
Hey, bud.
This is her first day ever playing around.
Yeah.
It's my first day.
I've been showing her around.
Do you want to hear some music?
It's not too late to change your mind.
I'm busking for scraps.
All right.
Yeah.
Because I have a gambling addiction.
Oh, you too, right?
Yeah.
Oh, thank you, sir.
Thank you.
That's all I got.
I just moved on.
Thank you, sir.
I'm going to go get some food.
Oh, yeah.
Be careful.
Be careful with rust because you'll end up playing like for 14 hours.
Oh, yeah.
No.
Like the first five minutes I got on, I got ran over by a car.
Yep.
That's where it begins.
Everyone gets run over once.
Yeah.
Wait.
Can we run over somebody, Gumi?
Do it.
Well, I gave you your own car.
You do whatever you want.
Oh, my God.
I can?
Hey, by the way, since your car doesn't have a lock, you can run me over.
I don't know if you can steal your car.
Oh, shit.
You got to get it over with, you know?
Wait.
You are...
Oh, my God.
A freebie?
Okay.
I hope I'm backing up correctly.
Gumi, do it.
Am I doing it?
Where are you?
I can't see.
Did I do it?
You ran over my leg.
You ran my leg over.
I mean, that counts.
That sort of counts, right?
Wait, Gumi.
You should run him over.
He's doing it for free.
What the...
I'm going to run him over.
No, no.
Only the first time running over.
Oh, the first...
Wait, but Gumi's never ran over somebody.
Wait, Gumi.
Ask him for...
Ask him for a low grade because you ran out of gas.
Oh!
I ran out of gas, apparently.
That's why I couldn't run you over.
Oh.
Do you have any low grade fuel?
Anything.
I left that shock over there that's not completed.
Wait, you're poor?
Gumi, if you want...
You're poor?
What did you say?
You want this car instead?
Oh, wait.
Yeah, I want that car.
I'm going to the Canadian Embassy.
What?
How can you be poor and rust?
It's been four days.
I just got in yesterday.
Wait, you just got in...
Oh, yeah.
You're poor.
You should have...
I'm sorry, man.
Gumi, you know what?
I'm going to give you this armored car.
Yeah?
Whoa.
You got gas?
You didn't have this car because she wants this car.
Oh, my God.
Yeah!
Don't keep someone shooting at us.
No, no, no.
No, they're not.
Nobody's shooting at us.
Yeah, it's here.
Do you not hear those bullets landing near us?
Is this going to...
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, sir.
Because I saw how nice you were, I'm an influencer.
And I'm going to gift you that car just for how nice you were for letting me run you over.
Whoa.
Don't keep...
I literally gave you that car.
No, you just get all of that.
That's your whole car for you.
Just there.
We're going to leave now.
I get 100% of it?
Yeah, you get 100% of that.
Oh, my God.
You were so nice because you were like, let me run you over and I'm an influencer.
So I decided to gift you that car.
She's pretending that she fixed the car.
But it was my gift.
Yeah, you gift it to me.
So I gift it to him.
I'm like basically like Mr. Beast.
Are you beating his car?
The homeless doesn't give it to the next homeowner.
I just fixed it up for her just now, man.
She's so ungrateful.
Yeah.
Congratulations on your new car, sir.
Thanks so much.
No problem.
Tell them it was Mr. Beast.
What the fuck?
There's a red barrel.
There's a red barrel right here.
Oh, there's a red barrel.
Wait, that's fueling.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Why the fuck are you driving off when you...
I just...
Mr. Beast behind a casino.
Oh hey, look.
There's like fuel.
Alright.
Nice.
Wait, there's people talking over there.
Where?
Where is that place?
There's a building to our right.
What is that?
Is that a tavern?
Is that a bar?
I don't know.
Oh my God.
It's a role play house.
Wait, that's a role play house?
What does that mean?
No, tell me about it.
Tell me about it.
Go on.
Get up.
Hey, how you doing?
Come on.
Take a seat.
Hello.
This is my friend.
She joined...
This is her first time playing at Rust.
Yeah, this is my first day.
Oh, no way.
What's your name?
Hey, it's Doki.
Tell us.
Tell us two fucks about yourself.
Oh, okay.
My name is Doki.
My name is Baby Billy.
Uncle Billy.
Oh my God.
Hey, Baby Billy.
You are Baby Billy?
Who's Baby Billy?
I was calling your phone yesterday.
Oh, you was calling Uncle Baby Billy?
Yeah, I was looking so hard for you, Baby Billy, but then your phone number disappeared.
Are you off the grid, Baby Billy?
I'm sorry.
When you found me, I left my phone in the back of a car.
I got a new number.
Oh.
Yeah.
Thank God.
Well, it's nice to meet you, Uncle Baby Billy.
Represent the church with that father down there.
And we're happy to have you.
We're having a little bit of a meeting if you want to sit in.
Oh, shit.
What kind of meeting?
What kind of meeting is this?
We just have a daily church meeting.
Oh, shit.
I love politics.
I love to sit down in this meeting.
This isn't a cult, right?
No, no, no.
This is not a cult.
I'm definitely not a guy.
Definitely not.
I'm using a megaphone because I'm down here at the other side of the table.
Hey, so, Billy, so...
I'll use mine too!
Oh my god, they're so nice!
Oh my god!
Woo!
Yeah, I agree.
Money!
Listen, last night we broke even by, I think, 2,000 scrap, but the reason is because we was giving a lot of money away.
You know, we had lines of cards.
Aww, opening night.
Yeah.
Broke even?
What do you mean broke even?
I thought we were going to be millionaires.
See?
You didn't run your game.
The concessions are not even open yet.
The concessions are not open yet.
What kind of meeting is this?
Remember that?
I don't know.
I had already been in town for 13 hours by the time it came to fruition.
I'm sorry.
When money is to be made, money is to be made.
You think that in There Will Be Blood that Daniel Day Lewis, when he found the oil, he said, Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm an oil man.
I've already been working for two hours today.
He sounds white.
This is my son, bastard in a basket.
Now, he said, let me get that oil.
You left the oil on the ground, son.
I think we're in a cut.
I'm going to drink your milkshake.
I don't know how to get out.
I think we have to wait for the meetings now.
I'm scared.
He also fell asleep.
And that guy was taking exploits from him.
I have another piece of coin for you.
He had a bowling alley in his house.
I dare you to be sad with a bowling alley in your house.
All right, let's move on.
We got to get to business.
I don't want to keep you all here too long.
That was the business?
We all have another party where Bobo wake up to kick off the next day to Kasana.
Wow.
We need some new things running.
We got to have those concession supplies ready to go.
This church is funded by a casino?
And a rack of water in case they are parked.
What kind of religion is this?
We are going to try and have both the Russian roulette up.
That's you, Father Seale.
And our racetrack fully operational so that people can bet on the ponies.
You know what I'm talking about?
High rollers.
Stonewall's also been working on Operation Kaiju.
For those of you who don't know, Operation Kaiju is a fully autonomized self-defense system that if anything goes wrong in our town, we launch up droids like it's a Pacific Rim job in this bad boy.
And it kills anything that's moving, anything that's not moving, and anything in between.
So that's the kind of matters of business.
Hallelujah.
Yeah, from Baby Billy.
Uncle Baby Billy?
Does anybody else have any pressing matters?
Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
I have a question.
What's a Pacific Rim job?
Oh, that's the movie where they had mechanized units fighting Kaiju, but I combined it with a graphic sex act called Analangus.
Where you're looking out the outside of a butthole.
Analangus.
It was for dramatic effect, you know.
I thought that was the movie about like those mecha sharks.
Yeah, that's the one, but I just made it nasty so everybody pay attention.
Little Baby Billy.
Oh, okay.
Okay, thank you Uncle Baby Billy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Any other questions or things you want to bring up?
Hey, uh...
No, no, how many...
I've never watched Pacific Rim.
In terms of betting, baby.
Oh, sure.
Yeah, go ahead, Greg.
In terms of betting, how many horses are we going to get?
Cabus and I are running around town.
It's so hard to get them because they keep getting stolen.
We've got about four at the moment, but they take so long to find.
Yeah, I think... I think four is fine.
You want at least, what, six maybe?
I don't think...
No, I think four is fine.
Oh.
I think you don't want to bet on a...
We ain't going to have a show, place, and win like normal horse racing.
I think you're just going to bet on which horse you think you're going to win.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Hey, what religion is this, Gumi?
Hey, our new two people, you got anything you want to talk about?
Hey, I'm just...
Tell us a little something about yourself.
I'm just a little... I'm just a little curious here.
What... What religion is this?
Religion of blood.
That's a good question.
The Hall of Sun of Blood.
Ah...
That's not no bad question.
So, we worship the Blood God.
He is known by many names, Yog-Sagoth, Asriel, the Crusher of Elves.
Anyway, he is an Eldrige being that lives in the void of space.
There's Satanist.
Yeah, and...
Out loud.
is his way to night.
And we appease him by being our most untapped degenerate selves, you know, most faiths, the Buddha, and Jebus.
Oh!
Yeah!
I'm gonna learn from these mistakes.
Try to make sure you have a good time.
Oh!
And you guys make a lot of money?
Yeah!
Baby Billy the richest motherfucker!
Oh shit!
That's right I got friends!
Damn!
I got a race horse named Baby Baby Billy!
Baby?
You know, I think...
What are you trying to do?
You just find Baby Billy if you're looking for a mission or you're looking for something to do.
Or you just wanna walk around the castle.
What the hell are you doing in there son?
Now I had to kill that man about 50 times yesterday.
Oh that's uh...
Make a wish kid.
Make a wish kid?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
His dream is to kill me but uh...
You know some wishes ain't meant to come true.
You know when I was young I was stricken with a little bit of a gap and when I was in Make-A-Wish I wanted to meet Michael Jordan and play him in one on one basketball but they couldn't make that happen.
But you lived though.
We'd give them tickets to like...
Yeah, it wasn't a bad case of gout.
Yes!
I thought Make-A-Wish kids were supposed to be dying.
It was.
They didn't know what it was at first.
My feet was all slowed up.
You know, you're only supposed to have gout that bad.
I see.
Does anybody else have any other questions?
Anything I can help anybody with?
Any matters of business that BabyBinna should be focusing with?
Hoss?
Come on.
Stonewall?
So for the racetrack, what else do we need other than horses?
Oh, I think Chrissy was working on the racetrack.
I don't know if she's gonna be working up, waking up.
But she had a plan for it.
I think we got a lot of resources.
But if she tells you she needs something, you know, you gotta be Johnny on the spot and help her out.
Yeah.
For the racehorse and stuff, for the racetrack, we need a bit more stone.
But I think Kameis and I can...
We got it covered.
We need stone.
Alright, we got jacks though.
We got a few jacks.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can jack off.
Alright, we gonna get them jacks a lot.
We're gonna be jacking off a lot.
Hey, my two new lovely ladies at the table, is there anything that you wanted to do?
Did you want to...
You know, go on a mission?
Or you want some supplies?
Oh, yeah, we can go on a mission.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, did you want to maybe build a business in town?
We will help you with that too.
If you wanted to build like a...
I don't know, like a...
A pet shop or...
Can we...
Can we have a pet shop?
Can we?
I'm...
I'm good at farming.
Yeah, I got a store for you.
Oh my God.
There are a lot of rabid wolves around.
I love a pet shop.
If you need somebody to take it over, you could take it over.
It has vending machines.
I'll show you.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we love some of that good nepotism.
Woo.
Oh, nepotism.
Can I draw?
Can you draw?
Can any of you draw at all?
Oh, yeah.
We can draw, right?
Yeah, we were just at the art gallery.
You can draw?
Yeah, let's talk.
Oh, buddy.
Okay, let me know if you need me.
I got to talk to a horse now.
Come on.
We have a pet store.
I got one more thing to tell you.
If I were here speaking bad tongue, ill will about our God, I'm gonna gut you like a fish.
Oh.
We would never.
Keep that in mind.
Yes, sir.
Mr. Father, sir.
Don't step on my toes.
Oh, God.
Shredding on the boots.
Oh, no.
We would never do anything bad.
Is this a pet shop?
They're giving you a free house, Dokie.
Oh, my God.
They did a free house?
But I own this building.
Yeah?
Minus that one door.
But we can fix that.
There's a lot of free loot on the floor.
Oh, my God.
You can have this shop.
It's got all this stuff.
It's got furnaces in here.
Boxes.
Do you want it?
Yeah.
We would love to start a shop here.
Dokie, we could live up here together.
Wait, how did you get here?
Wait, I can't even move here.
Okay.
I can't move.
It's stuck.
I'm gonna unlock everything and you can change the code.
Hey, step, bro.
We're stuck, guys.
Oh, my God.
We made it, Gumi.
We joined the cult.
Made up money.
Oh, my God.
We can live here.
We can make this a cute kitchen.
And then we can work downstairs and wake up to our daily lives and work for the Blood God.
Yeah.
And if you need to remove any walls, just let me know and I'll blow them up.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, no problem, man.
Oh, my God.
We own all this?
Definitely, we can if you need a window or something.
We own all this.
We get free things.
Did the boxes have codes?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one's locked.
The one in the bottom.
Okay, there you go.
It should be open now.
You have the codes?
Okay.
Yeah, that was the one with the codes.
What about this door back here?
Oh, my God.
Guys, I get clothes?
Guys, who said joining a cult is a bad idea?
I literally got free water and food.
Should we be able to change it?
And fucking animal pelts?
Okay, it's 4-3-4-3 if anyone's asking.
3-4-3, okay.
4-3-4-3.
We made you drop everything after you changed the lock.
Oh, my God.
Gumi, we're set for life.
We never have to work again.
I'll do this one quick, Gumi.
I'll just make it 4-3-4-3.
Thank you.
Cults are cool.
This one is already the code.
Cults are so cool, Gumi.
We should have joined a cult earlier.
It's not a cult.
Oh, sorry.
Your religion is cool.
It's not a cult.
Not a gang.
Not a cult.
Okay.
Sorry, sorry.
This religion is so cool.
We should have converted earlier.
Have you guys ever been part of a...
Wait, we're going to get stoned.
If you need any stuff, just tell me and we'll get it.
Do we need to get baptized?
It's dark.
I'm kind of scared.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Have you heard of our baptisms?
Wait, baptisms?
No.
What's the baptism?
What if they baptize us in blood, Doki?
We'll get you both baptized later.
It's a secret.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I think they're going to drown us in blood.
I think they're going to waterboard us in blood.
We'll have an indoctrination of you two later, okay?
Oh, yeah, sure.
Does it hurt?
But because...
Um...
Don't ask questions.
Oh, okay, yeah, yeah.
Because this is the type of religion where we don't ask questions.
Unless you know...
Yeah, exactly.
You just devote your life to the blood gods with hope and prayers.
Okay.
Of course.
Of course, of course.
That makes sense.
Okay.
You guys said you converted, though.
Where were you from before?
Did you come from baptism?
Or where?
There's other religions?
I thought there was only one.
No, I don't think we even said the word convert.
No, I did.
No, you did.
You 100% did.
I just got here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, but maybe...
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, today's my first day.
I haven't heard of any other religions.
Well, yeah, I thought there was only one.
Why would there be other religions when the blood god's the one true god?
You...
It's true.
Why would you say there's other religions?
I mean, I mean, God.
Why did you say there's other religions?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You said you're converting.
I thought you converted from another religion that we didn't know about.
We were gonna have to go and take out the other cult...
I mean, um, religion.
I see.
I see the false prophets.
We gotta get rid of the false prophets.
Yeah.
I see.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
Wait, do you guys have the front door as well?
No, we don't have a door.
I don't think so.
We only have one door.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do you have the code for this front door?
Dude,
we just got so much free shit.
I know, right?
I told you.
It works.
Bro, he's fucking slipping.
That guy said there's other religions.
You okay?
I don't doubt.
I can't believe you implied there are other religions.
Do you have the code for the front door?
No.
Yeah, it's 4343.
Oh, yeah, okay.
4343.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Okay.
We need to get you guys some stuff so you can, um...
maybe, you know, have some privacy.
You guys have some lights here.
You have light.
You have to pray to the Blood God every...
every single morning you need to pray to the Blood God to keep the light on, though.
Oh, that's easy.
I was praying to him just now.
Yeah, that's why we're so quiet.
I was praying to him.
Well, that's like private.
It's between me and the Blood God.
Everybody knows.
No, no, no.
The Blood God wants his love public.
What?
What happened?
Okay, anyway, I'll let you two get settled in.
We'll be around.
We need to go get some stone for the...
for the basina opening.
Oh, yeah, sure.
Don't worry, we're gonna make... we're gonna clean the shop and turn it anew and make so much profit for the cult... I mean, religion.
Oh, my God.
Yes, for the... for the religion.
Yes.
Okay, be safe.
Let us know if you need help.
Yeah, of course.
No problem.
Bye.
Doki, they were fucking freaks.
But then we got so much free stuff.
Doki, you got a fucking free house.
I got a free house in water.
Look at that.
We're living the life, Gumi.
Remember, Doki, the code is 4343.
4343.
How do I...
How do I fucking...
enter your code?
4343.
Yay!
I can't believe it.
We actually met the blood god called.
I thought they were rumors.
No, they've always been here.
They've been here since the very beginning.
I thought they all died out.
Boy, this is such a nice house.
And we're protected by Uncle Baby Billy.
Yeah, Uncle Baby Billy.
I wanna rat that guy out to Uncle Baby Billy.
Because he implied there were other religions.
Yeah, do you remember his name?
It was like Ray something.
Rain Bird.
Should we rat him out?
He tried to tell us.
What if there was a test and he mentioned other religions on purpose so we could rat him out?
That means the shows were loyal.
Yeah, we should do it.
Yeah, we should.
We should rat him out.
Be like, one of your fathers implied there were other religions.
I thought it was just one.
Do we actually do it?
Let's do it.
I'm gonna give us this whole house.
Oh my god.
Okay, I need to figure out 4, 3, 4, Oh my god, you typed the code so fast.
Well, it's because I pre-typed it while you were busy talking.
Oh.
Where's Uncle Baby?
Where's our car?
Wait, did they steal your car?
And my car?
No, my car has a lock on it.
Oh, okay.
Wait, this is the Sheriff's office!
This is the fake Sheriff's office that you told me about!
Yeah, look, it's so fake they don't even have an actual door to the cell!
Oh my god, this is the fake!
Oh my god, I literally rode through this fake area.
Oh my god.
I renamed unnamed bag.
Somebody's sleeping bag is here.
Yeah.
We should put our sleeping bags...
Where's our cars?
Oh, it's over here!
Yeah, where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Remember, your car is unlocked.
They could steal your car whenever.
Yeah.
Wait, I think Uncle Baby Billy's in here!
Is Uncle Baby Billy here?
I love the creaminess all over my tongue.
Oh no, wait, that's him.
He can't ride about when he's there.
Can I take you to him?
Come, come, come.
You were eating something creamy on your tongue.
We can't ride him out when he's there.
We've seen my ice cream.
It makes me feel bad.
He said he likes mint chocolate chip.
I like ice cream.
Wait, you...
Have you had pistachio ice cream?
Pistachio?
I have.
I kind of like that one.
I don't like sweet stuff.
There we go.
Is that what Blood God likes too?
Um...
You know what?
I actually don't know.
I'll bring you to them.
Come, come, come.
Wait, to who?
Where is he bringing us to?
I don't know.
I like strawberry ice cream.
How are you going to snitch on him if he's here?
I know!
How are we gonna...
Why did he say strawberry like that?
He said starberry.
I don't know what...
What accent that is.
I'm just saying, if we get rid of...
If we like, ride him out, we can rise up in the hierarchy.
True.
We can become the higher disciple.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because we're like more devout followers.
I rebuilt your box.
Hey, Belly.
It's me.
The newcomers have some questions for you.
Before we take them to you.
Doki say you have something secret to tell them.
Oh, wait.
Actually...
Well, well, Guma and I, we actually have something private we want to tell them.
We have something private.
It's a private question.
Oh, you're talking about me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who's father are you talking about?
You're talking about Father Seer or you're talking about Baby Billy?
Uncle Baby Billy.
Yeah.
You tell him.
You tell me.
Okay.
We tell both fathers.
We'll tell both fathers, but it's a secret question.
We'll follow you.
Okay, Guma.
You ask us a secret question.
You take us to...
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this area?
Okay.
You tell them.
Father?
Be Uncle Baby Billy?
Yeah, we have a confession.
Are there other religions?
We were told there were other religions by the other followers.
I thought the blood god was the one true religion.
Mr. Rain Bird guy?
He told us about other religions.
Yeah.
Oh, now I ain't no heard about It made us confused.
I thought he was like... it made us confused and I don't trust his faith in the Blood God.
Really?
So my faith is rock solid right now.
Exactly.
And also I think it's important to understand this about Blood God.
You know, everyone's on their own journey and path of discovering and believing in themselves.
You can't force it.
It's like forcing a baby chicken out of the egg or a baby fetus out of the mom's womb.
Disgusting thought.
But you gotta let people naturally hatch and figure it out themselves.
You just can't run.
You just can't rip the...
You just can't rip it out of the...
You don't know the door of the explorer.
Hey!
That's the thing about the Blood God too.
We exist here to take in the lost members of this island.
So if you feel a strong pull to one of the other kingdoms, we encourage you to go over there and join them.
Have a good time.
We are always here if you need us and we will be unwavering in our faith and our commitment to show you a good time.
See ya.
And I might actually blow your brains out.
I know.
Yeah.
If I see you once you leave.
But he might not do that.
He might do that.
We crossed that bridge when we see that.
When we get to that bridge.
You know.
And you go on and explore those other religions.
But as far as I'm concerned, you are an enemy of the state!
So make up your mind!
Oh god!
No!
Wait!
Hold on.
Now.
Now they're just asking questions.
They're asking questions.
They're just asking questions.
We're only asking questions because...
while your followers, they brought up about the other religion.
So we got so confused.
We thought there was only one religion here.
Faith is confusing.
I'll tell you what.
I used to believe in a tooth fairy.
I had faith in that guy.
And you know what?
I saw that.
Every time I'd lose a tooth, I'd get a nickel underneath my pillow.
Yeah, but that was from the Blood God, wasn't it?
And one day I saw my daddy sneaking his hand underneath my head.
What?
Oh yeah.
So I think anytime...
That's kind of a bitch.
What was yours, man?
I'd wake up and someone was ripping out my tooth.
And then they'd run out the window and they said, I'm about to trade that in for a dollar.
I thought that was Blood God the whole time.
Oh my God.
Where did you grow up?
Ohio.
Anywho.
Y'all need anything else?
Y'all want to start setting up a business?
We can give you some supplies.
We were wondering.
They were saying that we're supposed to get baptized?
Stokie, why would you bring that up?
Y'all wanna commit to the church already, huh?
I mean, there's only one religion.
It would make sense if we committed to that one true religion.
Stokie, what?
You're doubling down.
We got the church fan right here.
Wow!
Pop in.
I can't.
You wanna perform a baptism?
Yeah.
Hey, Goofy.
What did you do?
We only got four seats.
One second, let me get a bigger church.
We are being devoted to the church.
And a bigger one?
Stokie, I think my game crashed.
No, you're in.
Oh yeah, come look at our three cars, hoss.
Ladies, come look with me.
I'll show you our cars.
What, you don't wanna join?
They're so nice though.
I'm using my two-way pager.
Nah, that's fine.
I'll catch up with you later.
You have toilet paper?
Okay, okay.
Oh, you're not a true believer?
Here we go.
See all these cars?
Wait till they kill your ass at the baptism.
These are the church's cars right here.
They're not gonna kill us.
They're so nice.
This is our religious fleet right here.
Oh my god.
Would that be for one of us too?
The blood god has blessed us.
The bang bus.
I'll bring the parts for us so you can get a boob.
Alright, hold on.
How'd he get in?
He has some lucky face.
Is this gotta gas?
Nah.
We're putting the parts in right now.
Alright, we're going on a church mission.
A church mission?
How long are you gonna be on, Doki?
I have another stream in three hours.
The door code is a boob.
We're going down to the river to do a baptism.
Wait.
A baptism?
Oh my god, we're gonna get baptized.
I'm walking in.
Oh shit.
Oh, you guys almost hit me.
Are you guys okay?
What happened?
Okay, come here.
Come here.
Put your guitar away.
Okay.
He's a terrible driver.
Oh my god.
Oh, I've done it.
I got praise B.
Jericho!
I love a good fetus.
I think we're moments away from having this car juiced up right now.
How do I get in?
I don't know.
How do you get in?
Alright, here we go everybody.
Whoa.
I need a passcode.
Boob.
Oh, it's boob?
Okay.
Which one?
What's boob again?
Oh, eight.
You son of a bitch.
From 404.
I went down to the river to pray.
Worrying about that good old day.
Okay, I'm gonna jump to nothing.
It's a little sketchy, I'll be honest.
Come on, we get baptized!
Scooby, let's go!
One more, children.
Oh my god.
Hallelujah!
We lost some.
Who did we lose?
We lost K.
Rool.
Hey!
Where is he?
We're being fired!
Let's go down.
Down to the river and pray.
Oh my god.
Look, he sings to the guitar!
I went down to the river to pray.
Worrying about that good old day.
And who should wait?
Yeah!
I went down to the river to pray.
Oh my god.
Show me the way.
All sinners, let's go down.
Let's go down.
Don't you wanna go?
Alright, we here.
Get out.
Oh shit, okay.
Alright.
I know, but it lost to the je ne sais quoi.
Alright, Scooby, you first.
We don't need you to baptize these ladies.
Oh god.
Come on, Scooby!
Don't you believe?
Alright, alright.
I do believe.
Come on and step into the water.
See you gonna baptize you now.
Y'all got beds in this...
Did y'all get a home or bed in this town?
No.
No, our beds are really far.
Hold on, who got cloth?
Don't drown, don't drown.
Oh damn.
I think we're gonna die.
They're killing us.
Hang on one second.
Don't baptize them yet.
I think they're killing us.
So tell us about where you were before you found the church.
Why would we need beds, father?
Where we found the church?
Yeah, where were you before?
Well, I had to pick her up.
She was right next to the church.
But she told me this fellow ran her over.
Yeah, someone ran me over next to the church.
Did you catch her name?
Yeah, Esfren.
Who is he?
You know what?
You're not the only person.
You're not the only person to mutter those names that you've been run over by.
Well, is he a bad person to the church?
He wants to kill a lot of people from the church.
Wait.
They seem to only run people over outside the church.
Yeah, they're a bit of troublemakers.
Does he hate the church?
Yeah.
Are they heretics?
I hate the church.
I mean, listen.
Are they heretics?
Yeah, but here's the thing.
You just can't restart VODs all the time.
Otherwise, in Blood God, we're gonna run out of resources to give us for all of our VODs.
We just let the bygones be bygones.
And we let those who are still trying to find their faith.
We let them find their faith.
So it's alright.
It ain't no big thing.
Let the water wash away the sins.
They just strayed from the path.
I see.
God, she really dig it in international school with that.
Hey, so, Hoki, you're a musical artist, right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I can draw.
So, um, No, no, musically, musically, musically.
Oh, yeah, I'm here too.
Yeah, I'm very talented.
So, Caymus can...
Caymus can rap.
Right?
So, whilst we're waiting for this, uh, you know, baptism to get on the way, you two do a little, um, a little duet, huh?
Oh, yeah, yeah, Caymus, show us your rap skills.
He'll be here.
I'll show you then.
But not right now.
Alright, ladies, you're gonna need these.
Hold on.
There's one sleeping bag.
How do I make a s- 10 seconds.
Now you can call this place your home.
Oh!
Hold on now.
Make sure you sign that bag.
Yeah, sign it.
One more second.
Hold on.
Just put it out?
There you go.
Yeah, you put it down on the floor.
Right there.
Grab it and put it on the floor.
Okay.
So just drop it?
No, you hold it in your hand and then left click.
Oh, okay.
Yay!
Perfect.
Y'all members of the town, congratulations!
Yay!
Yippee!
You can commence with the baptism.
Let the ritual commence.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Yes, Elias, Elias, come out and step into the water.
Should we look into your eyes when it happens?
Not too far.
You ain't wanna drown.
No, no, no.
I just want y'all to just...
understand.
When Blood God came, he rained down a...
a bloody storm upon this...
store...
of...
soil...
and these lands and that...
that blood is filtered on through into the center of this planet.
Inside of it.
Where is this the name?
The pla...
The core of the planet is the swishy-swashy blood.
And it all recycles and it runs through everything.
It runs through us as well.
And Blood God, he forgive us for our sins.
Ever since day one.
The day you're born.
And every sacrifice that's made...
is a cost to everything.
Every death.
Every life.
And in doing all of that...
There is a cost to everything we figure out.
You must be reborn.
You must be sacrificed.
All three episdio and down the road.
And you see...
And just like that there is a circle of lives.
And thecence Good shot, Cavers!
And sacrifices must be made.
And that's just how that cookie crumbled...
Amen That's what we say.
Let the water wash away those sins.
Alright, let the water wash away those sins.
And you shall be reborn to that sin.
You shall be reborn to that sin.
Don't give me 100 wait till our sleeping bag timer's up.
Why?
Wait, I have 670 seconds.
I can't wonder where we are.
Oh my god.
We're in the Blood God Cult!
We did it!
We did it, Goobie!
We're part of the one true religion!
We're in the family!
Yeah?
What's wrong?
Nothing.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna be reborn in 100 seconds.
How do you feel joining a cult?
I don't know.
I feel safe at the same time.
Yeah, but this...
This will be the only time we ever get shot.
They'll protect us.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if that's true, man.
I'm pretty sure we'll get shot and they can't protect us everywhere.
No, there's no way.
We'll just say that the Blood God will punish you.
Oh.
We're gonna be reborn.
The way they punished that guy that was running in the river.
Yeah.
Yeah, Eerov that was just randomly swimming in the river.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I have 35 seconds on mine.
Wait, how come you...
Oh, because you had...
You should tell them that there's a cooldown.
They're gonna be like, where are the girls?
They lied to us.
They're just like, where did they go?
It's okay, don't worry.
You tell them that we're still just waiting.
I'm waiting for mine.
9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2...
Apparently Eerov has been trying to kill the cult for like 2 days.
But has not been successful.
That's...
I mean, look, I would...
I mean, how?
They're like a fucking army.
Guys, it's not a cult.
They're a real religion.
How dare you would say that to our one true God.
Okay.
Oh.
Alright!
I have been reborn!
We did!
You did.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
How do I do this faster?
Right click.
You have been reborn!
Oh my God.
Yeah!
Wait, how do I fucking...
And that's bad to teach you that death can be a sweet and fast and quick thing.
Cause we're gonna experience a lot of it out here in these rust kingdoms.
Wait, why are you hitting your body?
Yep.
That doesn't matter as much as what you'll say on...
You know, some people say that being reborn is kinda like the similar sensation you get when you get your butt kicked.
But as you say it's just gonna be one whole wax.
At first it hurts.
But then it feels good.
Ohhhhh.
Have you done that before, Uncle Billy?
Yeah, have you done that, Uncle?
Oh, yeah, don't let baby Billy's beard fool you from the neck down baby Billy is smooth like a porpoise.
Damn!
Damn, Uncle Billy-Billy.
Watch how fast I am in the water.
I'm like Michael Phelps.
Look at that.
Oh my god!
He is like a porpoise.
Oh baby Billy got some of that lake water in his lungs.
We've been reborn Gumi!
We're believers now!
And by the way, let it be said, whenever you need a drink of water, we live right next to this river.
You come up and gulp that river down a little bit and you get refreshed.
Oh my god!
The more we drink, the more we believe!
Back to some water!
Oh I see!
He was getting right from his gun.
Woah!
He's flavored!
Yep!
Bang bus!
Oh yeah, he's pretty flavored.
Oh no, baby Billy!
I'm Billy!
You don't wanna drive?
Gumi, you should drive!
You're a great driver!
I lost my guitar, Gumi.
But he sings every time he drives.
That's true.
I lost my guitar, Gumi.
You have to ask them nicely for one.
Maybe.
Don't get a little bumpy here.
Oh shit!
We're also, while we are highly religious, we're also highly progressive as well.
Yeah!
As is the society!
If you choose to go by they them pronouns, we will respect that.
Even if we decide to sacrifice you.
What?
If you are dumb, I will sacrifice you.
Oh, okay.
All right.
All right, everybody.
Welcome to the church.
Oh my God.
Who's that, baby Billy?
Hi.
Who dat?
Hey, how you doing?
What's your name?
I'm Mr. Traveler.
My name is Francis.
What's the stop?
I'm Mr. All.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm just here.
I'm looking for people.
We have a restaurant off the road.
And I'm just looking for customers that we could bring and introduce.
You know, free food too.
But I see you guys might be busy.
Free food?
Unless you guys are hungry and would like to make a visit.
Wait, what is that?
You got a restaurant?
Sounds like a trap to me.
We have a beautiful restaurant.
Hey, listen.
We got two new...
We got two recently reborn members of our church right here.
Why don't you take these two?
Feed them a nice meal.
Oh, yes.
We're hungry.
Absolutely.
I would be honored.
Let's go.
Hey, you all want to take the church, man?
It's not too far.
Let's go.
Alright, y'all.
You go with him.
But if you need the van, just let me know.
You know the passcode.
Yeah, yeah.
We know.
Yes, sir.
If anyone else wants to come by, we'll be back.
Oh my God.
Bye.
I stole their horse.
Let's go.
So you should ride off with that shit.
You're a customer of this shop.
I mean, didn't you enjoy the food?
It was pretty good.
Wait, we were?
You come back?
We never ate there before.
We've never been there before.
No one's been there.
Yeah, this is our first time.
I woke up.
I was less hungry.
Let's go, Yoinks.
Let's show them the true greatness of this restaurant.
You gotta be a returning customer from that last experience.
Yeah, yeah.
Being reborn took up a lot.
It's an abandoned supermarket, so it's not too far.
What if I just ride off?
So you guys are a part of that church?
Yeah, we just joined it like five minutes ago.
What's it been like?
They wouldn't let me in.
Wait, why wouldn't they let you in?
I have to go get a car.
I'm Canadian.
Wait, I'm Canadian?
They let me in?
Are you sure?
What part of Canada are you from?
Are you from the bad parts of Canada?
No, I'm from Ontario.
Oh!
I don't think it's a Canadian thing, sir.
Yeah.
I think it's just a youth thing.
They don't like you.
Yeah.
I think it's because you were like... you're like half naked.
Poor!
Did I give you a car?
Yeah, maybe it's just poor except poor people.
Yeah, but it didn't have gas.
I don't have gas.
You could have sold it.
That's it up ahead.
That brick building is the restaurant.
We're almost there.
Oh my God.
Okay, I'll meet you guys there.
Yoink.
Maho.
Oh my God.
They're going to feed us free food, guys.
Okay.
Let's see.
Hello, Doki.
Hello!
Welcome.
Is this the restaurant?
It is!
Come on in!
Yeah!
The guy told me that you're giving out free food!
Oh yeah, please come have a bite.
Oh my God.
Let me get you something to eat, Doki.
Yeah!
Hey, fancy!
We actually have another visitor on her way.
She's actually driving right here.
So, I guess we'll start getting the food ready.
Oh my God.
Yeah, I'll start cooking.
We have Yoinks.
Yoinks is also outside.
He's stopping by after that last dinner.
Are you guys...
Are we our first customer?
Looking for some more food, Yoinks?
Oh no, we've had a few.
We've had a few.
How's the restaurant been going?
Hop inside.
Yum yum yum.
Oh, business is pretty good.
Pretty good supply of food coming in.
We do have other tables if you did want to have more of a private dining experience.
This is more of like a chat with your cook kind of experience.
Oh, a chat with our cook?
You know what?
I like a chat with my cook.
Oh, perfect.
Perfect.
So, here you go.
I got this cooked up fresh for you.
I hope you enjoy.
Oh!
Where did you get this meat?
You know, it kind of just walks right in here, Doki.
Oh, really?
Just...
Oh my god.
Wait, that one's raw.
Yeah, I got you.
Doki, I think they're gonna kill us for our meat.
So, Lola, how's your wife been going?
So, like...
So, they said this is like free food.
So, how are you making the money to buy the meat?
Uh...
Uh hmm.
Uh-huh?
Um, we have our ways of getting the meat.
That's a very nice gun you have there.
It's fancy.
It's...
We uh... We appear to have some loose products.
Doki, get out!
Run!
Hurry!
Doki, run!
I...I have to...I have to get out!
Doki!
Get out!
Doki get out!
I have to get out!
I have to...I have to get out!
I have to go!
Go!
Get back here!
Save me!
Don't let them kill me!
Get back here!
Get up over here!
Damn it!
Get back here!
We're gonna tell the blood god about you!
I think they were catapults!
They were catapults!
Oh my god, tell me!
Okay, they're pretty horrible shots though, not gonna lie.
Oh no!
They're pretty bad shots!
I wish I should have stole their fucking horse.
Should we go back to your place?
Wait, is this your... what are you doing?
Are you fixing the car?
Wait, get off the car.
Okay.
I put a lock in it so no one can steal it.
Ah, I see.
Is this your house?
Wait, who's car- Oh, public garage!
Okay, Ducky, the code is 4343.
4343.
Okay.
Man.
We almost got murdered.
I know.
We need to talk to baby Billy.
Bro, I think they killed Yoinks.
I think they killed the random guy that was with us.
Yeah, they just came back.
More!
The bank bus is gone.
Oh, wait.
No, it's right here.
Yeah, yeah.
We're out of gas, Ducky.
Oh no.
Did we just park it here?
This is their place.
Right here.
Oh my god.
I can't believe we lived.
Our house!
Please come to the little pool!
Does our- Oh my god, it does!
We're living it!
We survived!
And we have a pool!
What's that, Ducky?
What's that?
Oh, it's him!
He almost got killed!
There's cannibalism- Cannibals living down the street!
Yeah!
They tried to kill us for our meat.
They told us there was free food.
What?
Who?
They live down the street!
They're like- At the abandoned supermarket.
Yeah!
They're like over there!
Oh my god.
Try to eat some of the followers!
I actually have- Okay, no, no, no.
We'll- We'll- We'll- We'll- One for you and one for you, okay?
Yay!
They tried to give us human meat to eat.
And a worm.
But don't eat that.
Don't eat that though.
Don't eat that.
Unless you want to.
I'm not- I'm not judging.
I'm okay.
Uh...
Yeah, what are we gonna do about the cannibals down the street?
Hold on.
How far down are they?
Are they outside of the village or- At the market?
At the supermarket.
The abandoned supermarket.
At the market.
Did they- Did they- Did they- So you see we were talking about ice cream earlier.
Did they have the kind of, you know, the vibe that you thought they like, you know, were like, Hey kids, I've got ice cream coming to my shop.
No, Uncle- Uncle told us to go!
Like he trusted them too.
Hey!
That's the cannibal!
They're cannibals!
No!
He shot at us!
He shot at us earlier!
He's shooting!
No!
Listen guys.
What have you been doing to the new- to the- our new members of our cult of religion?
I just- hold on.
Listen.
What happened back there was a mistake.
Alright.
Listen.
What is these?
What are these that you gave us?
What are these?
That's not mine!
That is not mine!
That is- that is- listen.
He's the shop owner.
I had no idea he was gonna do that, okay?
Oh no!
Hey, I'm not gonna lie.
At least it's cooked, right?
No, he wasn't shot at us!
No, I didn't.
That was- that was so- I didn't do anything.
Listen.
I just wanted to come back and apologize.
I had no idea he was gonna do that back there.
And you know, I brought some extra food, you know?
For the road.
Oh my god.
More?
No way.
What?
Explain yourself.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, I can't believe we survived.
So, um, that man...
Yeah?
...isn't working alone.
So next time you get yourself in a similar situation, it's a different person, be careful, because there's a group of them going around doing that.
So be careful.
Oh.
I like the way this guy talks.
Oh my god.
Thank you for- thank you for looking out for us.
What?
That conversation ended abruptly, but okay.
Okay, Camus, we need to repair our car and get the stone.
We've been trying to get the stone for like an hour now, right?
Alright, we should...
Alright, I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna call it here.
Yeah, I do like British people.
What?
Let's go back to your place, so I can like be safe.
You two haven't seen any kingdoms yet, have you?
No, we only- we only saw the- the Rusty Kingdom.
We haven't seen the other ones yet.
Oh, yeah.
The- the Rusty Kingdom.
The Rusty Kingdom, you mean.
The- the Rusty Kingdom, you mean.
What is that, a card stone?
Maybe.
We need- we need a farm stone, but we can- we can drop you guys like kinda close if you- if you wanna go visit the- What?
Who's that?
I think this is Stone- this is Stonewall.
Come- come- come- Stone, Stone, Stone, come- come- come- wait, you met him already, no?
Oh, yeah.
I just couldn't see the name.
It was too far.
Oh, okay.
Stonewall's currently getting his load of stone.
I think we need to go to the car so we can have more bangbusters.
Doki, say no.
Say no when they ask everyone to go.
I don't suppose you have to prepare stuff on this side.
Oh, okay.
Okay, what did it say?
This one's Doki's car.
We found a garage earlier.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, this one's mine.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
This is my car.
It's a lot of gas.
Okay, okay, nice, nice.
Um, I never called your name, Arie, actually.
I only called Doki's name.
I didn't catch yours.
It's Goombie.
Goombie, okay, okay.
What?
Did the people ever call you Gummy?
Gummy.
I can't say you hate it.
That's okay, I guess.
Hey, that's all I need.
That is a no.
Oh, no.
Gummy, are you okay?
Gummy!
Oh, my God, you did not just do that, right?
No, hey, I said no.
Don't, don't do it, no.
Do a flip.
Oh, no.
I called you.
Hey, hey, hey.
I asked.
Doki, on the other hand, is intentionally saying it.
Personally, personally, I wouldn't have that.
Oh, no.
I was just asking.
No, no, no.
Okay, go.
I don't think, Arie, I don't think she's okay, guys.
Come, come, come.
This will cheer you up.
Have you seen another kingdom?
Let me repair the car and I'll take you to another kingdom.
Yeah.
I'll take you to another kingdom.
I'll be surprised.
Wait.
Let me repair the car.
Can you take us to Team Rocket's kingdom?
Are they gonna kill us?
Oh...
Oh, hell nah.
I'm not gonna kill you guys.
You guys don't trust me right now.
Wait, what's wrong with Team Rocket?
I'll tell you what.
You guys have had a lot...
What's this?
Nothing is wrong with Team Rocket.
I've never said anything is wrong with them.
But there's gonna be people there.
I'm not trying to go with those hella people.
But they're nice people, right?
With turrets.
Are they not nice people?
Yeah, but they're turrets.
Wait, do you guys wanna use...
You've had a long day.
Oh yeah, we had...
Do you guys wanna use... come here, come here, come here.
You can use the premium...
The premium?
Premium?
I think Team Rocket has nice people.
Mm-hmm.
Oh my god!
Who means...
Who?
Okay.
Let me repair the car.
Open the door.
Go ahead.
Open it.
Oh my god.
I'm peeing.
Do you have enough toilet roll in there?
Or should we get you some more?
Do you have enough toilet rolls?
Oh, I think she didn't need it.
I didn't need it.
Okay.
Wait.
What do you think this chicken's filled with?
Cock.
Wait, can you flush?
Oh, Doki, look!
What?
Oh my god, there's so many horses!
Okay, I've got stuff to repair the car.
Do you like all our horses?
Oh my god!
We're gonna use them later.
Oh, are these the race horses for the casino?
Wait, we have three now?
I wanna poop in.
Yeah, yeah.
Look at how much poop's on the floor.
Oh my god, so much fertilizer.
You can take some poop if you like.
What are we doing to do with the poop?
I think he wants you to eat it or something.
Okay, go.
Okay, let's...
Wait, where's the car?
Where's the car?
Okay, Miss, where's the car again?
It's over here, right?
They're gonna give us premium car!
Rusty Kingdom would never!
You're right.
They would never.
They would never give us free premium stuff.
Yeah.
Well actually they kind of would.
They tried to earlier.
No they did.
They put me in the torture chamber.
Well that was grandpa.
Oh my god.
This religion is pretty nice.
Yeah.
I like this religion.
Wait what are you doing?
I just landed a balloon right there across the street from the casino like 10 minutes ago.
Oh damn.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Here come here!
Wait what?
You see this thing?
What?
I have the codes to this because it's Mr. Bo's thing.
Mr. Bo?
What is this?
Oh it's like a casino.
It's a casino.
It's a spa too!
Wait did they take over it?
Oh my god.
Did they change the code?
They did.
That's it.
Where is it?
What are you gonna do?
Okay.
You're gonna demand them to give you a code?
What's the code?
Is it even online?
I message on Discord.
Oh my god.
Why would he change the code?
I think because someone tried to run in here and steal.
I mean it is next to the cult.
That's true.
It is next to the cult village so it makes sense.
Wait they're fixing car for us right?
Yeah you should ask them for gas for your car.
Yeah but they're giving us a better car.
Yeah are we going?
Hell yeah.
I think they're leaving us.
They're literally leaving us.
Oh.
Are we taking you to the...
I think so.
Okay we'll cheer you up.
Isn't this a two-seater?
No no no no.
Hold on watch this.
Wait.
Boom.
Get in again.
Whoa!
I feel so safe in those now.
I'm gonna get a snack real quick.
Okay get...
Okay enjoy your food.
So you have the option if you flex your E muscle you can open and close your windows.
Oh.
You might be going through some dangerous places.
Yeah it's locked.
Oh wait hold on.
Oh wait oh get out of the way let me open them for you.
Alright.
Okay there you go.
Sorry the children's lock was on.
Yay!
What?
I'm 25.
Where did you...
Oh that still makes me feel old.
You said you wanted to go to Team Rocket right?
Yeah Team Rocket.
I like Pokemon.
Okay I'm going to Team Rocket.
Can I close my window please?
Can I keep my window open?
Sure.
You have to get out after...
I'll just look out her window.
Okay okay.
We'll be fine.
We'll be fine Gumi.
Yeah you'll be fine.
I'll look out your window.
Yeah I feel so safe.
Yep yep yep yep.
Okay so since you guys are already excited bye.
Yeah.
Bye.
We should do something.
We should sing a car song.
A car song?
Like what?
Oh say can you see by the dawn's early light.
What so proudly we hailed at the twilight's last gleaming.
The star so bright in the night.
That it was so bright.
The moon so bright.
Oh say can you see by the dawn's early light.
Beautiful!
That was beautiful!
Sorry that was a bit bumpy wasn't it?
Yeah it was.
That was so good holy...
Okay Dokie's turn.
No no no.
Oh my god what food have you got?
I feel like...
I feel like the host should sing for us.
It's the last last night of your life.
Baby tonight...
The creeper's gonna steal all our stuff again.
Where were you?
Wait why did we stop?
I throw my pickup in the air sometimes.
I had to pick something.
Creeper let's go.
Okay how about this one.
I've got a really good car song.
Yeah yeah.
Do you ever feel like a plastic bag?
That's where you guys come in.
Wait what's that song?
Who's that by?
It's by...
Is that what old people sing these days?
Yeah yeah it's by Catherine...
Yeah I'm only 25 I don't know that song.
Yeah I only know...
Katie who?
Who?
Alex Gibbity Toilet what?
What's his name?
You know any songs by Ariana Grande?
Sorry sorry guys.
Sorry I can't help dancing.
I love... I love... I love... I love Aranis Grandius.
I have a...
I think he just casted a spell on us.
I see how he's...
Shh shh.
You will meet our witch later.
Don't worry.
Oh.
Oh is that song from Glee?
What was I gonna say?
Oh.
Oh my god I love...
Don't stop believing.
I know that song!
That's from the Glee people!
You will not forget me later.
Sorry that's the what?
The Pee Pee Foot?
That's from Glee!
Nah I love Glee.
Glee was my childhood.
When I was your age I loved... I watched Glee.
Oh my god.
I remember seeing Glee on YouTube.
Hi Billy.
Hey Billy.
Question for you.
Do you know what Glee is?
You talking about the show with the high school kid that sing the song?
Yeah!
Yeah.
Can you tell... Can you tell Kameis what it is?
Kameis doesn't know what it is.
We're trying to explain it.
Oh it like a... It like a...
Like a high school club for... for... for...
theater kids and young homosexuals.
And they sing songs together.
They do like theme songs.
They call it Glee Club.
That's pretty accurate.
No no no no.
They theater kids and homosexuals.
They can be both.
Some of the theater kids will also be homosexuals.
Yeah and some of them were straight.
Baby Billy like Glee a lot.
Cause Baby Billy like to sing.
You know but Baby Billy is...
Oh my god.
What's your favorite song from Glee baby?
What's your favorite song?
Oh.
Oh shit.
I don't know.
Oh you put one spot.
You put one spot.
5,500, 600 men.
Oh that's from the Rant.
Yeah.
I like the episode when they did the song Closer by the Nine Inch Nails.
Oh my god.
I don't know it.
Wait how does that go?
Don't Stop Believin' is a good one.
How does it go?
We were just singing Don't Stop Believin'.
We should sing it together later Billy.
Don't Stop Believin' Hopped on this open-ended ceiling and Oh wow.
We're so insane.
Oh my god.
That was beautiful.
You let me violate you Oh.
Skibbity Toda's got nothing on us.
You let me desecrate you You let me desecrate you Help me I thought about my inside.
Oh I wish someone would desecrate me.
Help me I got no soul to save.
Where did you go Kumi?
I'm on the roof of the car.
Help me get in my car.
I wanna fuck you like an animal.
Oh yeah.
That's beautiful.
You drove that car.
Oh thank you.
Oh my god.
That was amazing.
I can't believe we got that for free.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Sun's going.
Yeah.
Okay bye guys.
Bye.
Get in get in get in.
Get in bitch we're going shopping.
Can't believe we got that song for free Kumi.
Why did you call me?
Me?
I said get in let's go fish and go shopping.
Oh no you said fish.
I said let's go fish and go shopping.
I'm a 25 year old woman.
I only listen loud.
I was about to tell you a secret.
Oh yeah that's that's that's it.
I was going to tell you guys a secret.
Yeah what's the secret?
This is a big secret.
What is it?
So you mentioned um you mentioned skibbity tortoise outside of of working for the church.
I have another job in something that I cannot say.
You have another job?
This is why it's a secret okay.
Does Billy know?
So you see skibbity tortoise.
No no no.
Guys guys guys guys.
I think we should snitch.
Guys guys guys.
Everyone out.
Oh oh okay.
Why?
Everyone out.
Okay.
Okay so I need you guys to make a blood pact right now.
I mean blood pact right now.
Oh.
Everyone everyone everyone in.
Even wait does Keynes know?
Do you know about the secret?
No no Keynes doesn't know.
I'm only trusting you three with the secret.
You three are going to be only...
Did he consent to this?
Let me make a promise.
Keynes do you agree with this?
You better blood pact.
No.
Keynes.
I thought we were homies.
Guys guys come on.
Blood pact.
I just want to know what it is.
You can trust me.
I trust you.
Thank you.
I just met you but I trust you.
When I tell you.
When I.
Okay.
We have two.
We have two people.
We need one last person.
Ruby, come on!
Join the blood pack!
It'll be so funny!
It'll be so cool!
You're gonna like it, I promise.
I promise you won't regret this.
Come on!
Peer pressure is cool sometimes!
It's okay, she's into it.
She's just getting scraps.
I need her to swear an oath that she won't tell anyone the secret, that's why.
But Stonewall just came by and he heard it!
No, he just heard the secret!
Okay, what's the secret?
Quick, blood pack, go!
Yeah!
Okay, so... Skibbity Toilet... That's all your blood on the floor, okay?
Skibbity Toilet is going to release merchandise at Christmas time.
What?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but you didn't... but that's the secret.
Okay, but yeah.
Then game?
You're gonna be able to buy it.
Wait, do you...
And... and... in... in the church though, you will get early access to get it if you're a member of the cult...
Really?
The church.
Yeah.
You work for Skibbity?
No, that's the secret.
Oh my god, we're gonna get...
Top secret.
Do we get free merch?
But... but... why doesn't anyone else know that they're part of the church too?
Because I... this is... this is... I'm cutting a deal to make it exclusive to the church early at some point.
This is a super busy ass room.
Yeah, this is the worst place to tell a secret.
Yeah, I was gonna say this is the worst place to tell a secret.
We could get run over.
Okay, but shh... okay.
Okay, shh... okay.
Okay, let's go to the...
Can we meet Mr. Skibbity?
Let's go... um...
We're going to...
We're going to the Team Rocket.
Guys, chat, don't leak, guys.
We made a blood pack.
Don't leak.
We can go to Team Rocket, but you're gonna die if you try to go in because they have auto turrets.
No, Doki said she'll stop them.
Oh, damn.
Yeah, yeah, I know one of the people there.
I'm the people here.
Doki, contact Mendo immediately.
Oh, yeah.
I'm the people here.
Best I'm DMing Mendo right now.
There's another horsey there.
There's a horse there.
Mendo, we are heading to Team Rocket.
Do not kill us, please.
Okay, I messaged... I messaged Mendo.
Nice.
I don't know if he saw the DM.
Am I driving on the right side of the road, guys?
Yeah.
I don't have a license.
Oh, wait, you don't have a license?
But I thought you're old!
No, not here.
I only have...
Being old doesn't make you smart.
Oh, it doesn't?
We're here, Doki.
Wait, is this Team Rocket?
No.
This is... this...
Welcome to Team Rocket.
It was a tour!
I've never been here.
Well, the turrets are coming up in a second.
Oh.
You don't have to be scared of them.
This car has windows.
Windows in the back, but not in the front.
Oh, why are you walking away?
Why are you walking away?
Why did you both walk away?
Yeah, I thought we...
Hello?
There's a turret.
We've come to visit.
Wait.
But we're kind of scared because there's turrets everywhere.
Yeah, me too.
The turret is currently off.
You're chilling.
Wait, really?
Ready?
Hi, Gumi!
Are you sure?
You would never lie to Gumi, right?
How do I look?
Yeah, I would never lie to Gumi.
Yeah, see?
We're safe, guys.
Gumi, I told you.
Okay, let's...
Okay, but we do have some crazy people on our island, though.
So, yeah.
You gotta be on the lookout for them.
But...
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
You can escort us, right?
Yeah, you wouldn't let us get killed, right, Ray?
Yeah, you wouldn't do that.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, see?
They said yes.
I'm convinced.
Yeah, you look...
You look super cool.
He hesitated.
He doesn't think so.
I know he did.
I thought you brought...
I thought you brought Jen in for a second.
And I was about to have to go get my gun.
Oh, no.
We're not even gonna kill people here.
Don't worry.
We're telling a story.
We're giving some visitors.
I like your...
Okay, never mind.
I get what you guys are saying.
Who are these guys?
Hey, we're visiting.
It's my first day.
Call me, bro.
I understand.
You guys are just re-saying the story.
I can't trust anyone right now.
You've lied to me before.
That's your fault.
You lied to me before.
I'm telling you.
Whoa.
Bye.
Bye, guys.
I am sick.
This is gonna be fun.
We're going shopping.
Whoa, did you guys build this?
No, you find it.
We're going shopping.
Shopping?
Oh, my God, Gumi.
We're gonna go shopping.
Don't push this button.
I'm in charge of this button.
Yeah, I won't push it.
Wait.
Are there any, like, safety areas here?
I don't feel so safe up here.
Yeah, the casino.
How do you fly this?
I think it's from that button.
I don't know how to go.
It's just one button, though.
Sorry, I have to count, so I go quiet.
Why do you have to count?
Oh, is it because of the...
It takes a lot of concentration.
Oh, it's for the hot air balloon.
You gotta time it perfectly.
I see.
So there is...
Do you actually understand?
I think we might die if she starts getting distracted.
I think we have to keep our conversation to ourselves.
Yeah.
Do you know how to fly this, Ducky?
No.
Or were you just saying, I see, as in you understood?
I just said, I see, because I thought I understood.
If we steal the fuel storage right now, we could kill her.
And us.
That would kill all of us.
But it would be pretty funny.
Yeah.
It would be.
I mean, what happens if I...
Oh, there's like 38 fuel in there.
What if I take like 10?
Yeah.
And then you bring it back to your car that we left at home.
Okay, I'll take 10 and you take 10.
I don't want it.
I don't even have space.
Do you think I'll notice if I take some?
I don't know, but we're about to hit the ground, I think.
Oh, okay.
See, we didn't steal anything.
Wait, we're back here.
This is the spawn, isn't it?
I think this is where we're supposed to be.
But I have to go ask.
Oh, wait, just kidding.
I'm in the wrong thing.
I'm supposed to be in J16.
I lied.
Okay, we're going back up.
Unless you guys need off.
Do you need off?
No, we'll head over.
Okay, let's go.
Yay!
Wait, J16?
That's near my home.
Wait, yeah, that is near your place.
That's good.
We get to go back to your place.
Wait, whose place?
Where are you going?
Oh!
J16 is near Gumi's place.
That's her house.
Where do you live?
Yeah, Gumi, where do you live?
I don't have a home.
I live between three places...
Four places now.
Yeah, she's a nomad.
We just recently joined a cult.
For a home and food.
Do you guys have any guns on you?
If you have guns on you, put them away.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I put mine away.
Okay, put them away.
Cause there's this plane coming.
It'll shoot us.
Okay.
Yeah, it's away.
Oh.
We can call it.
After... I like how we went to Team Rocket and just instantly left.
Yeah.
After meeting a people, we just instantly left.
We just got in, man.
And then we're on a trip now.
We're like, woo, hot air balloon!
And then we just left.
Maybe we should've just gone back.
We had the chance to.
Yeah.
I mean, we... they weren't hostile.
We left... yeah, we left the two guys behind.
Well, they were kind of freaks.
They were.
I mean, we're in the cult.
Everybody's a freak in there.
We literally met cannibals.
What the heck?
You made us do a blood pack out of nowhere, man.
Yeah, and talked about skibbity toilet.
That man must be like in his 50s or something.
Cause he felt old.
He tried to be cool.
He tried to like talk...
You know like that meme where he's like, howdy fellow kids?
Hey kids!
Yeah!
So how's the skibbity toilet?
He's like, how's the skibbity toilet?
Yeah!
So scary.
I wonder if you can push somebody out accidentally.
Yeah, why don't you stand in front?
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah, go, go.
Why are you backing up?
I felt that push!
I felt it.
Sorry, I got excited.
Wait, we're running out of fuel.
We've run from 32 to 16.
And I didn't take any fuel.
I'm a little scared.
Are we gonna make it?
Yeah, we'll make it.
Where are we right now?
We're heading to what?
J16?
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Oh.
Oh!
Someone's shooting at us.
Yeah, somebody shot at us.
I think I know who shot at us.
Who?
It's Ryan.
Oh!
Why are they shooting us?
I thought we're friendly.
They're mean.
Wait, who are they down there?
Who is the people shooting at us?
Dude, that's Ryan.
Ryan was shooting.
I have no clue.
They might be trying to get something.
Ryan?
Ryan Higa?
Yeah, that was Mr. Pickles, Ryan Higa.
Why the fuck is Ryan Higa shooting at us?
Well, it's common to shoot at any air balloon because they could be enemies.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, guys.
It's the Ryan Higa.
Yeah, he's my teammate.
Yeah.
Is he a nice person?
He's the one that showed up when you were in front of our house.
That was him?
Oh, he was the one that saw me almost breaking in and then he gave me money!
Oh my god, I got scratched from the Ryan Higa.
Okay.
I didn't even realize that was him.
Yeah.
Woo!
Thank you for the ride!
Thank you!
Great stuff, everybody.
Good work.
Yup.
Yeah, I was there!
Wait, where are we going?
Let's go back to your house.
Okay, I have to go...
You have to go pick up my car.
Where was your car?
We left it back at the church.
We need to find a horse.
Oh, yeah?
If we see a horse, we fucking steal that shit.
Who's that over there?
My bad.
Whoa.
Did we just come over the door?
Hello!
Welcome!
Hey guys, are you guys also a club?
Can I get a chicken soup?
Hello!
I'm gonna ask for this to be made.
Look, look, look, look at the hat!
Oh!
The boonie hat?
What is it?
Take the hat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's beautiful.
Wait, why are we... where are we getting shot at?
Imagine if you could wear that...
He's stuck.
It would... nobody would shoot at you.
Only that thing.
No, it's not...
If you have not shot, you'll be fine.
I put a box there for you to jump on.
Here, here, take a hat.
Please take a souvenir.
Thank you.
Nice.
Oh, that's nice.
What do I do with this hat?
Put it on.
Hi cutie!
Where's Spinky?
Hi.
Wow.
I'm supposed to bring him a present.
Spinky, can you come?
Goomy?
Where's Goomy?
Where did Goomy go?
Nice.
Okay, I'm coming.
Wow, thank you!
Yeah.
Perfect.
You fit perfectly in.
I love fitting in.
I'm trying to.
Okay, I feel like we're entering another cult.
She's crazy like...
Are these the other religions they talked about?
No.
Okay, I think I'm gonna start running.
Wait, but it could be a cool cult.
We could get more free stuff.
I'm leaving.
Oh my god, that sight.
That is so good.
Oh my god.
Look into the distance.
Is this a Pepe cult?
That's amazing.
Why does he have boobs?
Is this a cult of Pepe?
Wait, you guys can see my sign?
How?
I think this is a Pepe cult.
Oh no, we are...
We're watching right now.
Wait, where are you Goomy?
I'm going home.
Wait!
Wait for me!
Where did you go?
I'm literally running home right now.
Where's home?
Which way?
I'm going south to...
I-20.
Where's I-20?
Goomy, wait for me.
And then I'm going to kill myself.
And then I'm gonna spawn in my car.
Wait, but like...
What?
You're gonna lose your stuff.
No, not if I put it away at home.
Oh, wait, can you wait for me?
So I can live in your...
So I can squat in your garage?
Listen, fine.
I'll build you a little room off the side of the garage.
Yay!
Oh, I'm bleeding.
No, I ran into a cactus!
Because I was so busy looking at the map.
Alright, I'm running to...
I-20.
Where's I-20 again?
Oh, wait, I ran the wrong way.
Don't worry.
Oh, there it is!
I-20.
That's your house, right?
Yup.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Don't stop believing.
Oh my god, a freak!
He's on the side of the road!
There's what?
I found a horse.
Wait, I'm trying to find my horse too.
What do you mean, my horse?
My horse.
You don't got a horse?
Yes, I do.
I always find horses.
I gotta put back my wolf hat.
I can't believe it!
Now we're part of two cults!
Yeah.
We should tell Baby Billy about the second cult we found.
You think that wiped them?
We should tell Baby Billy about the skippity toilet thing that that guy told us.
And he said he was giving a secret from Baby Billy.
Yeah.
Oh, he's not Baby Billy.
He's not gonna like that.
Baby Billy doesn't like secrets.
Yeah, Baby Billy needs you to tell everything.
Uh huh.
I can't believe...
I can't believe he would keep a secret from Baby Billy.
After everything he did for that man.
Yeah, like baptize him.
Like he gave him a home and everything.
And then he's willing to like fuck over Baby Billy by keeping a secret?
And he was the one that told us about the secret?
Yeah.
But we didn't know about the other religions.
We didn't know about the other religions until he told us about it.
Yeah.
Blasphemous.
I don't think he's a true believer of the Blood God.
Well I don't think so either.
I think he's a liar.
I think he's a spy.
I think we should kill him.
Wait, we gotta strip him.
I think you also died.
And then we both respawned at the church.
Wait, but...
You just need one driver.
Yeah, but...
Don't you wanna go pick stuff from...
the free church house they gave us?
Oh, that's true.
And then move it to your house?
Yeah, into the house I'm gonna build you.
Oh, that's so true!
That is so smart.
We should join that other cult, the Pepe cult.
And then get some stuff as well.
They look poor.
What?
There's the Pepe cult.
You outside?
Yeah, that's me.
I hear someone running outside.
That's me.
How... What's the code?
434?
No.
What's the code?
I don't think I can tell you that one.
Stop knocking.
Open up.
Gumi, open up.
How am I supposed to, like...
put my stuff away?
I'll give you a chest, man.
Well, I need to be inside.
No, you don't.
Yes, I do.
And my stuff is outside and people are gonna loot it!
I'm in the garage!
Wait, you're in the garage?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Are you saying that so I'll stop knocking?
No, I'm literally not in the house.
Open up.
I'm in the garage.
Oh, my gosh.
No, I see you.
How do I get in?
Stop knocking, man.
I'm waiting.
I'm literally...
The other side's open.
Yeah!
No, it's not.
You have three doors.
Wait, what?
Oh, there it is!
Yeah!
What?
Nothing.
These two boxes on the left and right are yours.
Okay.
Yay!
All right.
I'm thinking about who to close off to.
How do we...
Kill ourselves here?
Press escape and then click suicide.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, and then we spawn at Doki Reborn, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I'm back.
I'm in my car.
Wait, what?
How did you...
My car has...
Um, a bed in it.
So I can respawn in my car.
Wait, what?
How are you gonna pick me up?
What?
With my car?
Where is your car?
At the church?
Oh, wait, where am I?
Where is the church?
Oh, the church is in front of me.
I'm at the church.
You left your car here?
Oh wait, I forgot your car ran out of gas.
Yeah.
I don't remember where... I actually don't remember where...
It said R5.
R5?
R5...
Oh, R5 is this way.
Okay.
I'm heading over to R5.
Alright.
I'm heading over.
Yay!
I can't believe we did so much in just...
No, I'm ready to take a nap.
Yeah, in just like three hours.
We did so much today.
Yeah, we got indoctrinated.
We made so many new friends.
We met Uncle Billy...
Yeah, named them all.
We met Uncle Baby Billy, Ray-Bans, uh...
Ray-Bans?
Canes, Stonewall, the cannibals, uh...
Bader Sire, uh...
Alright, I'm there.
I'm here now.
Blood God, are you there?
Okay, where are you?
Oh, is that you?
No, that's Stonewall.
Oh, there you are.
Wait, how do you have clothes?
Because I went into the house.
What you s- Oh, wait, wait, yeah.
Did you get everything?
Should we get more stuff?
No.
Wait, where is our stuff?
What?
Did you die?
Or why are you naked?
Yeah...
Alright.
Time to yoink.
Yoink.
No, I have to pee.
Let's see.
Where are the other clothes?
Uhh...
That's all we had.
Oh.
Wait, there's a hat.
Did you grab the hat in here?
There's a hat?
Oh, there's a gun.
There's ID cards.
Oh, there's vitamins.
Wait, is there a hat?
I have this.
There you go.
I'm not naked anymore.
It's time.
I'm ready to swim.
What the hell?
I'm ready to dive in.
Wait, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I can't...
I can't get out of here.
Okay.
I'm ready.
4343.
Wait, what?
Oh, there you go.
Okay, I'm gonna take off my goggles.
Alright.
Back home we go!
Our second home!
Yep.
Yay!
What an adventure we had.
I know.
Thanks for giving me the tour, Agumi.
Yep.
I think I would have definitely died.
There's a maybe that the server might close in two days.
Oh yeah, no, I heard.
The server's supposed to be up for like seven days or something.
But it might last for longer depending on how people feel about it.
Yeah.
Depends on if people wanna keep playing type deal, right?
Yeah, so...
You better be back on before the server closes.
I mean...
I feel like I learned a lot from the first day.
What an adventure.
Oh, look, a casino.
Hi Mr. Puno!
Oh my god, you almost killed me!
Hey!
Hey, it's Dosey Dory.
I know.
It's me!
Alright, what are you guys up to?
Yeah, I gave her a tour.
Yeah, we joined a cult.
Oh.
Yeah.
The one and only cult, right?
Wait, like a Mischief's team.
It's called the church, man.
Oh, sorry.
We joined a religion.
No, no, we joined a church.
Oh, you wanna get baptized?
Wait, wait, have you got baptized yet?
No, I'm part of Rusty Bones.
Yeah, you can be part of both.
It's a religion.
Rusty Bones is not a religion.
There's only one religion in this server anyway.
You're just taking a rusty bone.
Hey, type 2.
Oh!
Uncle Bobby Billy.
Maybe Billy.
We found another person who wants to get baptized.
Uh, you know, I mean, the church is not really my...
You wanted to get baptized, right?
Yeah, you wanted to get baptized, right?
You wanna join?
17,000 profits?
Who is this guy?
Where's Bobby Billy?
Alright.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
He said, oh, praise the Lord!
We're here to expand the church!
Alright.
Oh, wait a minute.
Yeah, follow us!
Follow us, IKUNO!
This is the village.
Yeah!
Yeah, get back in the car!
Oh, wait, get back in the car?
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait, is this not it?
Okay, sure.
Keep your hands off my horse!
Wait, that's the guy that tried...
No, that's... No, he isn't!
No, he wasn't him!
What are you doing here?
I gave you a car!
Leave!
I was the one that gave you the car!
It's still a car!
Okay.
Where's...
Where is he?
Where's... Where's Uncle?
He said he's on his way over.
Oh, he's on his way over?
Yeah, here, we'll take you to it, IKUNO.
Yeah!
We'll take you to get baptized.
You're gonna believe so hard.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Yeah?
I was thinking... We found someone who wants to get baptized.
...until he's here.
Oh, what is he doing?
Oh, you're in for a treat.
Oh, this guy wants to believe!
He wants to get baptized!
Oh, well, hey guys, you heard him.
Ten minutes.
We had some more human meat.
Do you remember the guy by the supermarket that offered you guys the pistachio ice cream?
Yeah?
The cannibals?
Yeah, yeah, the cannibals.
So, we ran into him again and the true blood god might have eaten some.
So, he's currently actually on the toilet.
Oh!
I see.
Oh, okay.
Well, hey.
We'll have to try again later.
Well, oh darn.
No, uh, no...
No, no, we can wait!
Don't you want to believe?
You should, uh, whilst you guys wait, you should maybe...
You should maybe bag them so they don't have the timer thing that happened earlier, remember?
Ah, I see.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He needs a sleeping bag.
Wait, we...
I can get some cloth if you need some.
Yeah, yeah, we might need some for him.
For our new believer.
Okay, come, come, come, come.
Come, come, come.
Are you excited, Mr. Kudo?
Yeah, are you excited?
I gotta give Elm his stuff back.
He's at the Coliseum.
Oh, it's... we gotta...
He can wait, he can wait.
Yeah, yeah, he can wait.
I've got his guns.
He can wait.
It's 10 minutes!
He has plenty of those.
Guns aren't allowed in the Coliseum.
Guns aren't allowed in the Coliseum anyway.
So, he has to wait anyway.
Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah.
They aren't allowed...
Okay.
Have you heard good things about this religion, Saikuno?
Have you?
No, I haven't heard anything.
Wait, you've never heard... Kumi, tell him about all the great things!
Tell him about all the great things they did for us!
They gave us a free home, free food, free water...
They gave us a car...
I have 12 seconds.
They gave you this car?
Yeah, they gave us this car!
Like this car.
Drive to the river.
I'll meet you guys at the river.
Oh, yeah.
We're gonna take you to the river to get baptized.
I think there's actually an extra seat in here.
I'm going to be honest with that.
I think there's just an extra seat.
I need to take this car there as well.
Oh, you're going to love it.
You're going to love this place.
We were reborn and we believed so hard.
I'm so sorry.
I've never been happier.
I know!
I've been so happy ever since I got baptized.
Like I saw the truth.
I just joined today and now I realize this is the one true religion.
Wow.
So you guys are like PVPers?
Do you kill other players?
No, we just here to spread peace and love.
We just people to change.
Yeah.
And money too.
You know they own a casino?
Apparently they made it rain a thousand scraps.
Like you know.
Yeah.
No, no.
They have like their own casino.
Is this somebody's house here?
It's completely undefended.
This could be your house.
After you get baptized, you can own this house after.
I mean, I don't think I want this house.
You get to own what?
Property is expensive.
I feel like I got a better house already.
Real estate is hard, man.
Like look at that free water.
I do like the free water.
That is nice.
Is there any food around here too?
Like maybe some pumpkins or something?
Oh wait, Mr. Raybirds have food?
You have food for us, right?
Ah...
I...
You said the blood god would provide.
Sounds like a winded version of that.
Oh, I have some here.
I have this.
Oh my god, praise be.
The blood god does provide.
Thanks, thanks.
What is this?
A donut?
Oh yeah, donuts.
Yeah, that's great.
Yeah, you love donuts.
That barely filled me up.
I think I'm gonna need like...
Oh my god.
A beach towel.
That's for you.
Yeah.
It's sunny over here, so we've got to, you know, stay on track.
Place that down and...
Wait, look!
There's a pumpkin here!
Let me put it somewhere safe, like by this thing here.
I'm asking he shall provide.
Oh wait, pumpkins.
Wait, I need pumpkins actually.
I'm actually hungry.
Wait, there's like... Oh, is this mushroom safe?
Yeah, let's see.
Yeah?
Oh hey, a pumpkin.
Yeah, that'll help a lot actually.
See?
He provides.
I'm gonna eat my mushroom.
I need this food.
This actually helped a lot.
Yay!
Yeah, so, I mean the guy who does this, he's gone, right?
So I guess we can't...
No, he's coming right now.
He's in like one minute maybe.
I'll have to join later.
No, no, he's coming over.
He's coming over.
He's coming right now.
Yeah, appreciate the food, I guess.
Look, Elem's here!
Oh, Elem's here!
Hello!
Oh my god, thank you so much for saving it, man.
Thank you.
I was for sure...
Yeah, yeah, of course.
Hey, you here for the baptizing, Elem?
Oh my god, you wanna get baptized?
Oh wait.
Yeah, I'd love to get baptized.
Oh my god!
Wow, let us tell Uncle Baby Billy!
Okay, we'll get the father of the holy ark.
Yeah, this'll be great.
This'll be great.
Oh my god, baptizing!
Yeah, I got baptized.
It was great.
Honestly, 10 out of 10 experience.
We need another bag.
Elem, quick, quick, quick.
Before the baptism, put this down.
Put this down, quick, quick.
Put it down.
Hurry, Elem!
Is there any pumpkins around here?
I'm starving, I'm starving, guys.
Wait, do we...
Here, come here, Elem.
Here.
Don't worry, we provide food too.
We're a good religion.
There's food right here, right here.
Yeah, let's um...
Maybe you can cook it up a little on this campfire.
Yeah, I have some coal.
Oh wait, I don't.
I died.
Oh, are you calling?
Are you calling Uncle?
Hello?
Tell him we have two new followers.
We did our job.
Hello, how's it going?
Oh, you have to put...
Oh yeah, here you go.
Wonderful!
Hey, where did Sakuno go?
Oh yes, yes, yes.
He's above, he's above the house.
I saw you took it off last night.
Do you not like it anymore?
Oh, there he is.
Hello?
Oh, hey.
I was just chilling up on the house here.
Ah, I fell in the water.
Okay, okay, okay.
What are you up to now?
Oh, I can't wait to see Uncle.
He's gonna be so excited.
You guys are gonna love Uncle Bobby Billy.
He sings for us.
Yeah, he's a great singer.
No, no, it's the one true religion.
No.
There's only one religion in this rest server.
You wanna brush the feathers?
LM, you didn't know I could see what you're saying.
I'll meet you.
Wait, what is he saying?
I don't say anything.
Wait, what?
What is he saying, Goomy?
Nothing.
I didn't say anything.
He said he was gonna kill us as soon as he touches the water.
And stay on the main road.
Okay.
I'm coming to call him.
I'm gonna be on the roof.
See you soon.
I don't think he wants to make Uncle angry.
If we have the launcher, we could farm Bradley.
I have a launcher.
Oh.
You have a launcher?
I have a rocket.
Yeah, after we get the rocket, we can go home.
After the baptism, we can provide you the launcher.
Where is Uncle?
You're gonna give us weaponry for being baptized?
Yeah, that's the best part about this religion.
You can ask for anything you want.
Okay, what the hell is going on?
What is this damn religion?
This sounds too good to be true.
What's happening?
I'm telling you, Ellen.
Mr. Baby Billy gives us stuff.
Yeah, Mr. Baby Billy.
When you see Mr. Baby Billy, you'll understand.
They're definitely killing us.
No.
No, no, no.
No, we're not.
They're definitely going to kill us.
How?
They're gonna take your LR300.
No, it's not a cult.
You're gonna lose your gun.
Your precious gun, gone.
It's a fucking cult.
I knew it.
No, it's not.
There's only one religion.
A cult means there's more than one.
They're going to take your LR.
We're not gonna take anything, we swear.
We're using this fish as well?
Give me the launcher now.
Show me the launcher.
They're not believing, Gumi.
Oh!
Oh, they shot me!
Gumi, show him the launcher.
You wanna see it?
You're gonna have to come over here.
They might have it over there.
I would go check.
Why don't you believe?
She actually has it.
See?
We would never lie.
We're just believers.
I told you.
I mean, we could kill Bradley with that launcher.
Yeah.
We could.
Who the hell is Bradley?
Who the fuck is Bradley?
The tank.
Are there people in the blood church right now?
Like Reinhardt?
I see someone running over.
He's coming over.
There he is.
I see him.
I didn't know they were running away.
There he is.
Straight south of us?
Let's do this backwards.
Is that the baptizing thing?
That's not great.
Yeah.
Where's Uncle Billy?
Where is Ryan Bird?
I don't know where he is.
I think Ryan Bird is picking him up.
Oh yeah.
Maybe we should chat.
Message.
Because I don't know how long we can keep them here.
I think they're getting antsy.
I think they're getting antsy right now.
I'm getting antsy.
I think we should just leave them.
They're getting antsy.
I feel like they might shoot at any moment.
I'm scared, Gumi.
Do you think we should just leave?
Oh no, no, no.
But we brought these people for Uncle Baby Billy.
Can't just leave them.
Uncle Baby Billy's not even showing up.
Where is Uncle Baby Billy?
Just type in the chat asking where he is.
Just type in the chat.
Okay.
Uncle...
Billy...
Our new followers.
They're getting antsy.
Oh my god.
There's a shack over here.
There's a shack?
Is there free food?
There's a bunch of nothing.
Their conviction.
It's wavering.
They're losing faith.
How could they lose faith?
Oh no.
Hallelujah.
They have to leave.
Okay, you have to make me a cell phone.
You forgot to make me a cell phone.
This cell phone material is hard to get.
Oh no, I'm actually starving.
Yeah, I'm actually starving too.
No, Uncle Baby Billy.
We can't do another baptism.
We lost new members from the church.
Where are you?
We gotta go to Rusty Bones soon, Gumi.
Probably someone's been kidnapped.
Who's been kidnapped?
I think Uncle Baby Billy isn't showing up.
I can't believe it.
The guy we believed in.
Do you think he was a fake all along, Gumi?
No, we can't say that.
But...
We can't say that.
He didn't show up when we needed him the most.
Wait, he's walking over.
Oh, he's coming over!
Wait, he's here!
He's here!
He's coming over!
Wait, he's walking to the church.
We are not at the church.
I knew it.
Hey guys, it looks like it might be...
He's here!
Oh my god, I knew it!
I think I gotta get going.
My faith did it on Weaver!
We gotta get to that.
That train yard crate is looking pretty juicy.
That train yard crate looks really cool actually.
I see him, he's walking!
Do you actually see him, Gumi?
You're like...
Listen!
If...
Once Uncle Baby Billy's done with it, I'll drive you guys to the train yard.
I'll drive you guys there.
There's nobody there.
Gumi, I don't see anybody walking here.
I think she's elucidating.
I don't think I see him.
I don't think I see him either.
Gumi, I don't think anyone's coming.
I'm gonna go to the train yard crate.
I think she left us.
Yeah, I think she just...
She like drove away from us.
Oh my god!
Wait, is that him?
That could be him actually.
That could be him.
I think that's someone else.
Who is that?
The crate looking kinda good, don't you think, Gellum?
Oh my god, look at that bear though.
Yeah, that's the train yard crate.
Am I right?
Oh wait, no.
Gumi's actually picking somebody up.
Wait.
She's...
Gumi, please don't.
Gellum, I'll be honest.
That was a death trap.
Like, a million percent.
Oh my god.
They're right!
They left!
Gumi, they fucking left!
They're like, that was a death trap.
Gumi...
I fucking...
Oh my god!
You just missed!
They ran away!
They didn't believe enough!
They literally ran away that way!
Oh no!
You just missed them!
Chase after them and give them some faith!
They just didn't believe enough!
Uncle!
Their faith wavered!
Oh shit!
They saw you shot the bear!
They saw you shot the bear and left because they got scared!
Oh shit!
I was bringing my favorite baptizing gun!
They got scared!
They saw you shoot that bear and ran off!
Uncle!
I don't understand!
Yeah!
Let's get them!
Oh!
Let's do it!
I can do 20 baptisms a minute with this gun!
Gumi!
They ran that way across the river!
They said!
We gotta go!
They went that way Gumi!
To the right!
Step on it!
Gumi?
Oh no!
We can catch up to them!
How dare they leave the baptism!
Yeah!
They were so ready and they took our food too!
We sheltered them!
We'll get them until Baby Billy!
We sheltered them and gave them food and everything!
Oh they took our food?
Yeah!
And then they left!
Oh no!
Now if you take the sacrament you gotta get baptized!
Them's the rules!
Of course!
We fed them and everything!
I felt like they were using us!
I got something that's gonna help you baptize all of them at once!
Hold on!
Really?
Hop out of the car real quick!
I gotta give it to you!
Okay!
Now this is a bomb!
When you find them, they got a little fuse on it!
All you gotta do is click!
And it'll drop right in the middle of them!
And then you gotta get the fuck out of there!
Oh my god!
Before the baptism starts!
Is she trained enough to do the baptism, Uncle?
Yeah!
I believe that she is!
Uncle Baby, finally I see them!
I'm gonna baptize them!
Right before you drop the baptism device, you gotta say, It's baptism time!
What's in here?
Oh there they are!
Are you ready to get baptized?
Jesus!
It's the blood god!
I'm gonna get the baby!
And you said after you baptize us, you promise us to come home?
Yeah!
Oh shit!
Is that an explosive?
Holy Jesus!
Who did that?
Jesus Christ!
Oh shit!
Uncle, I don't think you trained her enough!
Okay, pass them.
Where did you get those from?
It was the blood god!
Oh hell!
Right!
The blood god is right!
Uncle, I don't think you trained her enough!
I knew that...
Oh shit!
This is Uncle Baby Billy!
No, he's a believer!
Hello!
My name is Uncle Baby Billy!
We can hear you a lot better.
No relation!
And I'm here to baptize you!
Now I have a baptism device that baptizes at about 30 shells per second!
Praise be to God!
I will baptize all of you!
I got baptized as a child, it's okay.
Where you going?
Warful and triumphant...
Take cover and get out of there.
Good call!
He ran down there, Uncle!
I got the next one.
I want to say that was a good effort with that baptism device.
You had a lot of enthusiasm.
I appreciate that.
It was just her first time.
It was her first time.
Yeah, we gotta...
Those baptism devices ain't cheap.
So we gotta go back and get you another one.
Okay.
Let's go!
I might even run someone over!
Well, that's a...
We call that a road baptism.
Oh, a road baptism!
A road baptism?
That sounds fun!
Oh, God!
I can taste my teeth!
It's okay, we believed that we survived!
Uncle, we did it!
Gumi, I'm starving.
I see them!
Road baptism!
I gotta go to the restroom.
Go to the train yard!
Meet at the train yard!
Go to the train yard, everyone!
I'll tell you what.
Drive into the train yard, I will be baptized.
Yay!
Really?
We get this crate.
I'll also get baptized.
Oh, Rudy!
Oh, my God!
New members!
We're doing our job!
We just got baptized today, Gumi!
And now we found new members!
I'm getting poisoning!
Wait, how are you getting poisoning?
I need to put on a shirt.
Wait, do you have like a...
Inside, inside the train yard.
Why?
Okay, get in.
Oh, shit!
You need a passcode.
Do you have food?
I'm like starving.
No, I think Uncle Baby Billy ate it all.
I think my die.
I'm literally at one.
Where are we going?
Are you okay?
It's okay.
It's okay, you can repair the truck.
Oh, my God!
I have so many error codes just then.
Um...
Do you think Uncle Baby Billy is back yet?
I think he's like in a...
I think he passed out.
Oh, wait!
He must be getting those premonitions.
From the Blood God right now.
Oh, like an oracle?
Yeah, yeah!
He's getting an oracle right now.
He's getting a sign from the Blood God.
Oh, my God!
Hallelujah!
Where are we supposed to...
Are we supposed to be here?
I want to shoot someone.
I think I need to kill someone.
I think that's what the Blood God is telling me.
Wait, who are you going to kill?
A rocket?
No!
Why would I have a rocket?
I don't know.
I'm like... I'm literally going to die from starvation.
I'm just going to see if I can find food.
Oh, there's a balloon here.
I'm going to see if I can find food, you guys.
Or I'm going to die.
I'm literally going to die.
Where are the pumpkins?
I'm going to die.
I'm kind of thinking about coming over to...
I think...
Really?
What the fuck?
I just had a crew drive next to me.
Oh, no.
Where are the food?
Kumi, I'm 9 HP!
Kumi!
Don't worry, I'm begging for food.
You're begging for food?
Where are you begging for food from?
Just eat something.
Oh my god.
Where are you, Kumi?
He had no food.
Oh, Kumi.
I think it's time.
Wait, is Uncle Billy... Uncle...
Oh, no.
He's still AFK.
Hello?
Ray, do you have food, sir?
I do, yeah.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, Will's here.
Hey, Will.
Yeah.
Do you have food?
Really?
Oh my god.
I was starving.
Thank you.
I was just about to die.
Eat up.
Oh my god.
We lived.
We lived for another day.
Hello.
You want this, Harrison?
Oh my god.
Which one?
You only get that after you get baptized.
Oh, a better one.
Whoa.
Can I just say I love the block god and then...
Yeah, I can call Bobby Billy.
That's it?
Only after you get baptized.
You have to commit to a baptism.
Yeah.
You said I could do a...
What's it called?
A bro...
A bro baptism?
There's a... No, the road baptism.
The road one.
Yeah, yeah.
So he just has to stand there.
Ray.
Can you make us a rocket launcher?
Yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Follow Ray.
Okay.
I guess we gotta bro them.
I guess we do.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Wait, they're getting chased by bears.
Or by boar.
Wait, let's watch Elm die.
Whoa.
Well, we can still watch Elm die.
We need food really bad.
We can still...
We can technically still watch Elm die.
We can still technically watch Elm die.
Run, man.
Run, Elm.
Run.
Oh, God.
I need food.
Wait, we can watch him slowly.
I'm so weak.
Please don't hit me.
I'm gonna die.
I should have hit him again.
You should have done it, Goomy.
You should have done it.
Let me just spin around you, okay?
Wait, are you actually gonna kill them?
Are you actually gonna do it?
Are you?
Are you actually?
Are you actually gonna do it?
Let's get some food.
Oh, okay.
Yes, for anyone but Elm, yeah.
Please, please.
Please, right.
I'm good on food, actually.
There's like 500 pumpkins down here.
Can I eat one?
Do you even know where the door is?
Damn, Ray, you're so loaded.
He thought it was food.
Elm?
Hello?
We're coming.
It's really small.
I
don't think they're gonna open the door for us.
I need pumpkins, too.
Face me, Billy.
I need another baptism instrument.
I don't think they're gonna let you in, Gumi.
I don't think they're gonna let you in.
No, they'll let me in.
Okay, I actually...
How many food, man?
Because I'm starving.
Starving, I tell you.
One moment.
Gumi, I need you to take me home.
I might have to leave soon.
We'll be right out.
Okay.
I think they're gonna kill us, Gumi.
I think...
Gumi, I think they're gonna kill us.
I think they're gonna kill us and uncle.
I'm gonna...
Alright, Gumi.
You're gonna keep me safe, right?
Because I'm gonna call it here.
I think this is where my adventure ends.
Yeah, about that...
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
I need to drop Bobby, Billy, Baby, Bully, Billy, Bobby, Billy...
I need to drop him off.
Like, where did he go?
I think he's shitting me.
I think he's shitting.
Where did he go?
Where did the uncle go?
I don't know.
I'm gonna drive us back to...
The church, right?
Another town.
Yeah.
Yeah, get us back to the church.
I'm pretty sure they were planning on killing us.
No, because I'm in the same...
Rusty Bones kingdom as them.
Yeah.
They may be planning on killing you.
Me?
What did I do?
You're not in the Rusty Bones.
Wait, but why would they kill me?
I'm literally with you.
Oh, hey, a horse.
Wait, they need a horse.
Hey!
Wait, what?
We have uncle.
We have uncle here.
Is Biddy in there?
I think he's shitting.
He's blowing up the shitter.
He's blowing that shit up.
I told you.
He's baptizing the toilet right now.
He's mad because of that meat.
We have to drive him home.
We can take him home.
We can take him home if he can get out.
Yeah, but he's still in the toilet right now.
He's literally shitting.
He's like OOC shitting.
Wait, there's a horse here.
You guys need more horses, right?
Yeah, we do.
We do.
You can take that horse all the way home and I'll drop Bobby Billy off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll take this horse.
Remember I-20.
I-20, okay.
Wait, no, that's not the church.
No, but that's where all your stuff is.
The garage.
Oh!
What?
I'll just put this at the church first and then...
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, I don't need a horse.
Have you guys met Chrissy yet?
Oh, hey Chrissy!
Hello!
Gumi almost did her first baptism.
Chrissy is the one.
Yeah, I missed.
I should go pick someone up.
I'm sad I missed it.
Yeah, she missed.
She threw a baptism grenade and missed.
Can you give me a second baptism?
No, they left.
Can you give me a baptism grenade, please?
I have one of these.
I have a baptism knife.
Baby Billy!
That's me.
Oh my god.
How is it like baptizing the toilet?
Oh!
Did you baptize the toilet?
No, no, no.
My little rat had to go outside and make a duty.
And then he got some duty in his little dog head.
That's why the wash is behind.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh yeah.
We found a horse for the horse races.
Good to see you again.
Oh yeah!
Can you add me back to the team?
We came to do that.
And then we're going to go work on the tracks.
Oh yeah!
Sorry I took you off because you were sleeping.
Baby Billy, I'm going to go drop Dokia so she can go sleep.
Oh yeah, you guys can...
Alright, y'all.
You going to bed, Dokia?
Yeah, I'm heading to bed.
I hope I see you again soon.
Yeah, thank you for letting us join your religion.
Alright, y'all.
I had a great time for my first day.
I'll see you guys.
See you tomorrow.
Bye!
Goodbye, Gracie.
Goodbye, Rainbird.
Oh my god, that was fun.
I'm back.
God bless.
I thought you were gone forever.
Yeah, I was worried.
I was worried there.
Did you have a fun day, Dokia?
I had a fun day.
This was a good first day.
Bye guys!
Bye!
They were pretty fun.
I have another stream in an hour.
I got so caught up in the RP.
Yeah.
Baby Billy said he expects you back on tomorrow.
Oh, shit.
I don't want to disappoint...
the uncle.
Yeah, you would never disappoint Uncle Baby Billy, would you?
Yeah.
I feel like he'd shoot me if I don't...
That was a scientist.
Okay.
I don't have a gun now.
No, they get mad at anyone.
Oh, okay.
I was like, where did he come from?
Yay!
Now you just gotta be safe in your garage.
Uh-huh.
And you made like a whole room for me too.
Yeah.
Um...
If you can wait a total of five more minutes, I can make you a room.
A whole room just for me?
Yeah, a whole room with a fireplace in it if you want.
Oh my god!
I'm so excited!
I can even...
Guys!
See?
I am not a freeloader.
I'm not squatting.
I earned my place.
Well...
We got baptized together, Gumi!
Yeah...
I guess we also...
E-Rob got baptized too.
Yeah, we got baptized with E-Rob!
I think my favorite part is your baptism grenade.
Oh shit!
But that...
You know it was good effort.
The baptism grenade was...
Was good effort there.
Dude, I didn't expect it to go flying like that.
There was so much momentum.
It rolled down the hill.
I can't believe it rolled down the hill.
That was crazy.
And then...
I think he was trying to tell me that...
I had to pull the trigger but I was like...
Why is this shit blowing up?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
We're almost there.
I'm gonna go drink some water.
Oh, that's an empty water bottle.
I have so much water bottles from...
From today.
Yeah, I want those.
I'm always starving though.
I'm starving.
Well, you're only starving because we died multiple times.
And each time you eat food, it gets cancelled out.
No, we died like one time.
Oh, two times.
The baptism and the...
And the other one where we had to get...
Your car.
Yeah.
That was a fun day though.
Is this what it's like every day?
Yeah, it is like that every day.
What did you do yesterday on the server?
Oh, you see?
I logged on late.
Yeah?
I think I was also doing...
Oh, we're here.
You're also doing what?
Pull up in the back.
Wait, this is the wrong side.
There we go.
Alright.
Woah!
I'm okay.
Is there light in here?
Do you want me to build you a room or do you want to just sit down here?
I want a room.
I want my very own room.
I want to feel like I belong.
Damn, that map is really...
really got you.
Okay, stay right there.
Let me go get the tools to build you a room.
I'll build it right next to the garage.
Yay!
Wait, so what happened yesterday?
You didn't finish your story.
I don't even remember, dude.
There's so much that happens every day.
Like yesterday?
You said that you logged on late and then...
I don't remember.
I just went on many trips.
I got a free gun.
I got a cell phone.
I got mugged.
Oh yeah!
Yeah, a cell phone.
You think I need a cell phone?
Yeah.
Um...
Where's my blueprint?
Kazoo, hi!
Hi, Kazoo!
Hello.
Are you knocking on the fucking door?
Yeah.
Careful, Mr. Pickles is in here.
You don't know what he might do.
Oh, shit.
Don't tell him.
Don't tell him I'm here.
I thought you were living alone, so I was just fucking with you.
Oh, he's here.
Oh no, wait!
No, the door is locked!
No, I can't get back inside!
Alright, let's make it your little room.
Yay!
Hi, Kazoo!
Is that you?
Yeah.
Um...
My little house!
You gotta move.
I can't build it.
There we go.
Yay!
Is this gonna be my house?
This is gonna be your little room.
My little room?
I don't have to pay rent, right?
Oh, you will.
Wait, what?
But I'm poor.
Oh, no matter.
I can provide for other means.
I don't want it.
I didn't even tell you what my offer was!
You don't even know what the offer is!
I don't want it.
I could've sang for you!
I could've done a little jig.
Okay, let's make this...
Here, I'll put a door on it and make the code 4343 if you wanna log off here.
43343.
4343.
Oh, 4343.
Okay, guys.
Chat, remember that code for me.
Cause I won't.
Oh, hey.
There's me here.
Wait, what happened to my meat?
Did you take the meat?
What?
No.
What happened to the meat?
What meat?
Did you just take the meat?
I don't have any meat.
Wait, what?
What happened to it?
Alright, you can go to bed inside that room and I'll fortify and nerf it in.
Do I just leave the game?
Yeah, you just quit out and that's all.
Alright, guys.
Say goodbye to the server.
Everybody, quit.
Alright.
GG's, Gumi.
GG's.
That was fun.
Are you gonna keep playing?
Yeah.
I'm not streaming though.
Oh, you're just gonna hang out?
Alright.
GG's, man.
That was great.
Thanks for giving me a tour.
Very last minute.
I'll see you later, Gumi.
Hope you have fun.
Yeah.
See you later.
Log on tomorrow for a bit.
Okay.
Before your stream.
Bye-bye.
Let me know.
I want you to know.
Yeah?
I woke up perfectly, like, right on the dot when you messaged me.
Oh, wait.
Really?
The timing?
Oh my god.
Damn.
It was fate.
We were supposed to get baptized today.
Yeah, we were.
The blood god demanded it.
Alright.
GG's.
Bye-bye.
Bye, doggy.
Alright.
Huge thank you to Gumi.
Check her out on Twitch.
She's not streaming right now, but, like, for giving me a tour.
Super last minute for us and everything.
So, like, super huge shoutout to her for helping us out.
And I think, like, you know, I think it made it definitely a lot more fun touring around and meeting a lot of new people on the server.
We met a lot of new people today.
And interacted with some people that you know, we never would have had a chance to interact with if it wasn't for the rest server.
So I had a great time.
Anyway, guys, thank you for all the super chats and all the donations.
Guys, I'm sorry that I wasn't able to say thank you while we were streaming.
But thank you again for all the super chats, for all the new members.
We do have another stream in, like, in, like, 15 minutes.
So I'm gonna call it here.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Or stay up for the Kalao Tenjin.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!